bien monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues d'abord heureux de vous
retrouver après cette
suspension des travaux parlementaires
qui nous aura fait tous fait du bien sur
le ministre sommes heureux de vous
accueillir pour cette réunion
d'importance puisque
nous avons après vous avoir déjà entendu
sur les principes généraux nous avons la
possibilité maintenant d'entrer si j'ose
dire dans le vif du sujet puisque le
texte de la loi de programmation
militaire a été approuvée en conseil des
ministres et
entre en discussion chez nos collègues
de l'Assemblée nationale
413 milliards 413 400 + 13 milliards
soit 413 milliards c'est pas une mince
affaire c'est une somme importante et
donc
bien évidemment
nous allons à notre tour étudier avec la
plus grande attention ce projet de loi
de programmation militaire
d'autant que nous en savons maintenant
davantage sur le rythme de cette
programmation vous prévoyez une
augmentation des crédits de la mission
défense de 3 milliards d'euros par an
entre 2024 et 2027 puis de 4 milliards 3
jusqu'en 2030 pour atteindre à cet
horizon 69 milliards d'euros contre 47
milliards en 2024 et je dois quand même
souligner le fait que en deux lois de
programmation si ces engagements sont
tenus on aura quand même doublé le
budget
de nos forces armées ce qui est un point
très positif alors c'est une loi de
programmation qui présente bien sûr un
enjeu de finances publiques le total
annoncé est évidemment nettement
supérieur aux 295 milliards d'euros qui
avait été prévus lors de la précédente
LPM pour les années 2019 à 2025 autant
dire que l'effort qui va être demandé à
la nation dans un contexte budgétaire et
financier particulièrement délicat cet
effort va être important
alors bien sûr
après on commence à entrer dans dans le
vif du sujet si j'ose dire et en partant
de l'audition commune avec la commission
des finances et je suis heureux
d'accueillir Dominique delache qui est
rapporteur défense au sein de cette
commission donc au cours de notre
audition commune avec la commission des
finances le 12 avril audition de Pierre
Moscovici qui intervenait en tant que
président du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques on partageait une
préoccupation dont nous vous avions fait
part lors de notre président audition
sur ce que le président Moscovici a
qualifié je cite de hiatus de 13,3
milliards d'euros c'est à dire la
différence entre les besoins et les
crédits budgétaires prévus ce sera
l'occasion pour vous de nous éclairer
sur ce sujet on perçoit bien qu'il y a
près de 6 milliards 5 milliards 9 de
ressources budgétaires extra budgétaire
qui sont prévus au titre des recettes de
cession immobilière session de matériel
des recettes du service de santé des
armées reste bien sûr un peu plus de 7
milliards sur lequel il manque selon
l'expression du président Moscovici une
documentation précise sur le financement
monsieur le ministre vous savez que
notre commission est traditionnellement
hostile ou en tous les cas sceptique sur
les ressources extra budgétaires
l'expérience montre qu'elles sont
toujours incertaine et parfois bien en
deçà désespérance mais on aura
l'occasion de vous entendre sur ce sujet
qui est dans la presse du récent suscité
quelques petites réactions au-delà des
numération des techniques de report de
charge ou de l'invocation de la
solidarité interministérielle je crois
qu'il est heureux que l'on puisse
clarifier ce point et
nous donner un peu plus d'explications
de la même manière aucune précision
n'a été perçue dans le rapport annexé
sur le problème de l'inflation on sait
que c'est une somme considérable on
parle de 30 milliards mais ça dépend
bien évidemment le rythme d'inflation
que nous connaîtrons dans les années qui
viennent et personne est en mesure de
dire ce qui véritablement va se passer
mais ce que l'on a tout de suite compris
c'est que effectivement l'inflation aura
une incidence réelle sur cette loi de
programmation
enfin on a repéré un certain nombre
d'écho dans la presse au sujet du
porte-avion d'une demande à l'industriel
d'avancer une somme assez conséquente
il y a donc comme un hors champ
budgétaire dont le contour ne nous est
pas connu et sur lequel nous avons là
aussi besoin d'entendre vos précisions
alors quand on tenue quand on continue
de cette loi de programmation je vais
être assez bref pour laisser mes
collègues rapporteurs poser leurs
questions puisqu'ils vont m'entourer
dans la préparation du rapport derrière
la discussion des moyens à consacrer à
nos armées en vérité en vérité le vrai
sujet est bien celui de la stratégie et
du modèle d'armée que nous voulons
projeter à l'horizon 2030 et bien
au-delà et donc à ce sujet nous avons un
certain nombre d'interrogations le
paradoxe entre l'augmentation des moyens
de cette LPM et la diminution des cibles
à atteindre en 2030 sur des problèmes
sur des programmes qui étaient jusqu'à
présent emblématiques
je ne vais pas faire l'énumération pour
laisser mes rapporteurs le dire mais on
pourrait parler des on pourrait parler
des rafales des frégates des griffons
des hélicoptères H&M ils auront
l'occasion de détailler de détailler ses
observations
en d'autres termes les termes
d'économies de guerre et d'engagement
majeurs employés dans le rapport annexé
ont-ils encore un sens inauduisons le
carnet de commandes de notre industrie
de défense et si nous persistons dans
l'absence de masse de nos équipements
deuxième point de questionnement qui m'a
été rapporté par les groupes de travail
que nous avons constitué sur la LPM
celle-ci a été publiée le 4 avril
dernier et vos services auditionnés
postérieurement à cette date par les
rapporteurs nous répondent
systématiquement que les arbitrages
étaient encore en cours qu'il s'agisse
de crédit de renseignements ou de la
préparation opérationnel donc il y a un
petit point d'information je crois qu'il
faut jouer clairement sur tous ces
sujets qu'on puisse avoir toutes les
informations ce qui va faciliter le
travail de nos équipes enfin on peut
parfois avoir l'impression que c'était
le PM prend le contre-pied de la
précédente j'évoquais tout à l'heure
ceci ce sujet avec le rythme de
progression des Scorpions des
hélicoptères le report de chat est-ce
qu'il y a un changement de doctrine car
on peut tout à fait admettre que d'une
LPM à l'autre ce soit pas la
reconduction des services votés mais
encore faut-il qu'il y ait une analyse
qui sous-tend en quelque sorte ses
souhaits nous avions pointé je l'ai fait
moi-même devant vous la légèreté de la
revue stratégique qui avait été qui nous
a été proposé bon qui a été rédigé dans
les conditions que l'on sait mais qui
finalement n'a pas suffisamment
expliciter à nos yeux les choix qui sont
faits alors Monsieur le Ministre moi je
vais vous proposer au nom de rapporteurs
une méthode de travail pour
pour que nous puissions coopérer
ensemble selon l'expression que j'avais
évoqué devant vous cartes sur table
c'est-à-dire que on puisse aller au fond
des sujets et donc je vous propose à
l'issue de cette audition de vous
adresser un questionnaire écrit plus
détaillé dans lequel je souhaiterais que
vous vous engagiez jusqu'à ce que ainsi
que vos services pour qu'il puisse nous
nous répondre avant le 26 mai parce
qu'il faut qu'on ait le temps de
travailler si ce texte vient devant
l'Assemblée au mois de juin il est
indispensable en effet que notre
Commission puisse se forger une
opération éclairée sur le contenu exact
de cette programmation 413 milliards
c'est quand même pas une paye et ce qui
ne sera possible qu'avec des réponses
précises et exhaustive à nos questions
bien sûr vous confirmerez votre réponse
que je souhaite évidemment positive car
c'est la mission que nous confie la
Constitution vous proposons donc de
jouer ce carte sur table entre nous qui
à la fois et plus démocratique et le
plus sûr pour ne soutenir notre effort
de défense nous avons quelques semaines
pour mener c'est important travail je
compte bien évidemment sur votre
coopération et celle de vos
collaborateurs et je voudrais au passage
remercier les rapporteurs qui vont
s'exprimer qui sont en cours d'un très
gros travail qu'ils font avec le plus
grand sérieux parce que ça a été notre
méthode nous vous souvenez que nous
n'avions pas choisi de participer au
groupe de travail plus élargi nous avons
nous considérons que dans le respect des
droits du Parlement c'est au Parlement
de faire son propre ses propres
investigations et donc que nous en
rendrons compte mais les réponses à nos
questions seront bien évidemment très
éclairantes alors je vous rappelle que
cette audition est capté elle est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat
donc je vais vous donner la parole si
vous le voulez bien pour une
présentation générale puis nous
rapporteurs budgétaires qui massistent
de leur compétences dans la préparation
de ce travail puis Dominique delaige ou
peut-être Dominique delaige en première
dans les rapporteurs s'il le souhaite
honneur à la commission des finances
grand argentier de la maison et donc
après nous prendrons évidemment les
questions de nos différents collègues
nous nous donnons le laps de temps
nécessaire pour que cette première
audition soit constructive et je
rappelle que je vous ai proposé de vous
revoir pour une seconde audition qui
aura lieu après l'examen par l'Assemblée
nationale du texte puisque nous aurons
ici nous aurons à ce moment-là un texte
un peu sans doute un peu différent tous
les cas amendés de manière différente
féministe je vous laisse la parole et je
vous remercie encore de vous prêter à
cette audition
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
madame messieurs les rapporteurs madame
messieurs les sénateurs merci de
m'accorder ce nouveau temps d'audition
devant la route assemblée qui me permet
effectivement de d'être de présenter de
manière plus précise la programmation
militaire pour la période à venir je me
permettrais peut-être aussi d'accès mon
propos liminaire je le dis pour le
sénateur delène aussi sur les questions
financières comme la commission des
finances et là ça permet évidemment en
entrant en matière de de positionner de
préciser un certain nombre de choses
peut-être vous répondre tout de suite
monsieur le Président oui pour les
questionnaires mille fois oui déjà parce
qu'on n'aura pas le temps j'imagine
d'évoquer l'ensemble des sujets dès
maintenant et si je puis me permettre je
rajouterai aussi que ces questionnaires
ont du bon puisqu'ils vont faire ils
vont se faire par écrit et je suis
frappé de voir ma première année au
ministère des armées mais c'est mon
quatrième poste ministériel que la
matière militaire et sujette a beaucoup
de bruit beaucoup de rumeurs beaucoup de
choses qui sont relayées dans la presse
encore hier il était écrit que sur les
413 milliards d'euros 60% de l'enveloppe
irait à la seule dissuasion nucléaire
tout ça est complètement absurde les
questionnaires vont avoir du bon parce
que non mais une fois plus à peu près à
une beaucoup sur ces questions et le
questionnaire aura ce mérite c'est qu'il
sera le document qui sera le document de
référence qui restera aussi d'ailleurs
pour ceux qui nous suivront pour la
programmation et après et je pense que
ça a du bon pour aussi la transparence
et la qualité des travaux vous m'avez
invité à parler autant des sujets
financiers que des sujets de stratégie
globales et de format d'armée je vais
essayer donc de faire un propos
liminaire qui essaie de dresser un tout
petit peu tout cela et puis après
évidemment avec les échanges j'essaierai
d'être le plus précis possible bon déjà
le paysage et votre programmation
puisque c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de programmation encore ce
matin une nouvelle loi de programmation
pour la justice a été présenté au
Conseil des ministres il y a quand même
une histoire en matière militaire les
gaullistes ont souhaité dans les années
60 dès 1960 des lois de programme qui
permettaient justement d'inscrire à cet
endroit d'équipements majeurs notamment
liés à la dissuasion nucléaire sur la
pluri annualité il existait déjà des
lois de programme sur la République y
compris d'ailleurs sur la Troisième
République notamment pour les grands
équipements en matière navale mais pour
la première fois on a décidé d'aller un
peu au-delà sur la Cinquième République
et d'y mettre non seulement le format
des forces et petit à petit l'activité
ce qui n'était pas le cas au début les
questions liées aux ressources humaines
en y laissant de côté la question des
pensions aujourd'hui et la question des
anciens combattants au fond depuis les
années 60 plus d'une dizaine de lois de
programmes elles ont toutes été dans une
forme de continuité il faut bien le
reconnaître sur la dissuasion elles ont
toutes constitué en revanche des points
de rupture soit en fonction des choix
politiques on aura l'occasion de y
revenir pendant les débats soit aussi
tout simplement en fonction des moments
géostratégiques dans lequel la nation
française se trouvait
19791 évidemment la guerre froide
dissolution du Pacte de Varsovie des
lots programme qui ont suivi dans les
années 90 avec la professionnalisation
évidemment de nos armées les derniers
essais nucléaires décidés par le
président Chirac bref autant de
modélisations qui se sont faites
de bonnes raisons et pas que des
dividendes de la paix pour le coup pour
des raisons qui tenaient aussi à la fin
de la guerre froide et puis au début des
années 2000 après la guerre des guerres
que nous avons connues dans les Balkans
évidemment la question de la lutte
contre le terrorisme armé militarisée en
Afrique au Levant et évidemment
l'épisode douloureux s'il en est de
l'Afghanistan globalement ces lois de
programme on collées à l'activité
opérationnelle des forces et d'ailleurs
si je devais faire un bilan aussi de la
loi de programme dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons
2019 21 2018
2024 25 c'est évidemment aussi de
rappeler que nos forces continuent
d'être employées et je veux le dire ici
parce que sinon on se trompe évidemment
sur la discussion parlementaire à venir
on l'a encore vu il y a seulement 15
jours 3 semaines de cela avec
l'opération dite Sagittaire et puisque
nous reprenons les travaux cette semaine
au Sénat je tiens vraiment à rendre
hommage à nos forces armées dans la
qualité de la du travail qui a été
accompli dans la mise en protection et
l'évacuation de nos ressortissants
français au Soudan à et au-delà même
effectivement les ressortissants
européens ce que aussi d'ailleurs dit
quelque chose des missions de l'Europe
de la défense que l'on pourrait imaginer
d'ailleurs à l'avenir et si ce n'est pas
cela c'est toujours chômage c'est
toujours harpie c'est toujours évident
le bilan de barkham que je défends
devant vous bref on ne peut pas décorer
les le format d'armée les questions
organiques et toutes les marges
frictionnelles et report de charge du
monde évidemment ne viennent pas écraser
la finalité quand même de ce pourquoi
l'armée française est une armée d'emploi
et donc je le disais hier à quelques
députés plus insoumis que il était
compliqué de détacher les questions de
programme des questions aussi de ce
qu'on attend de nos armées évidemment
nos alliances par ailleurs sans quoi
évidemment on va faire
erreur alors dans quelle mesure
un programmation est une fixation ça
c'est aussi le deuxième point que je
souhaite développer devant vous parce
que vous serez la génération de
parlementaires aussi à devoir décider
entre rigidité et souplesse au regard du
contexte stratégique que nous
connaissons quand la mer était calme
il est clair que les programmations se
faisaient de manière plus scolaire et
quand les mers sont plus agitées soient
technologiquement on l'a vu avec l'atome
dans les années 60-70 soit sur le
terrain purement opérationnel il est
clair qu'il faut se garder aussi de la
souplesse dans la manière de construire
ce loi de programme ce qui m'amènera à
répondre tout à l'heure à la question
est-ce que les deux lois
20 voté en 2018 et celle que je défends
devant vous est-ce qu'elle se complètent
en bien des points oui pour en faire la
démonstration est-ce qu'elle commence à
traduire des pivots comme le dit le
cheveta major des armées en fonction de
la situation sécuritaire opérationnelle
ou de saut technologique ou de
militarisation de nouveaux espaces bien
oui certains pivots se font jouir et je
vais essayer évidemment les développer
de devant vous en tout cas moi je prône
évidemment
une loi de programme précise parce que
sinon c'est pas une loi de programme
néanmoins avec plus de souplesse vous
m'aviez dit dès ma première édition
monsieur le Président que le Sénat pour
des raisons que je comprends très bien
avaient mal vécu je cite le fait que les
revoyures de programmation ne se soient
pas faites devant le Parlement comme
cela avait été plus ou moins promis en
tout cas dans lequel il y avait eu des
engagements c'était dans la loi moi je
vous fais une proposition que je vous ai
formalisée par écrit mais puisque nous
sommes dans une audition formelle je le
fais devant vous tous c'est que regarde
la situation stratégique nous
considérons qu'il nous faudra en amont
de chaque loi de finance chaque année
avoir un temps de débat qui nous permet
de mettre à jour le cas échéance il le
fallait cette programmation dans le
texte qui vous est présenté
l'exécutif n'a pas le droit Conseil
d'État la rappeler d'ailleurs au
gouvernement et à votre serviteur n'a
pas le droit de de faire une proposition
ferme nouvelle sur ce que doit être le
rôle du Parlement dans le contrôle à
notre programmation militaire néanmoins
évidemment moi je tiens à dire que je
serai favorable à des amendements de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat qui
viendront préciser justement ce comment
les différentes chambres les deux
chambres pourront évidemment s'emparer
de cette question je le dis aussi sans
carte sur table puisque vous m'y avait
invité je pense aussi que ça permet
toutes les sensibilités politiques du
Sénat mais aussi de l'Assemblée
nationale aussi de faire carte sur table
sur ce qu'ils veulent aussi pour notre
appareil de défense je pense que ça
aussi quelques vertus démocratiques
deuxième des choses il faut assumer
l'alléa et je suis frappé dans les
commentaires de presse de voir que il y
a une approche parfois très scolaire sur
la programmation depuis les années 60 il
y a toujours eu des aléas tout
simplement parce que les grands
programmes que nous menons
jadis dissuasion moi font aujourd'hui
sur d'autres segments je pense au drone
en regardant le sénateur P1 bah parfois
on leur a Léa soit industrielle soit
en matière d'exportation en tout cas il
est clair que la copie bouge parfois
pour de bonnes raisons parfois pour de
mauvaises raisons et j'y reviendrai
aussi je serais amené aussi peut-être
d'ici la discussion en séance Monsieur
le Président à remettre à jour le
rapport annexé tout simplement parce que
la des l'Ukraine va continuer et que
donc si nous continuons de donner des
dispositifs anciens
anciens qui sont dans le format de nos
armées en dehors des 413 milliards
d'euros j'y reviendrai aussi dans un
instant bah il est clair que ça bouge la
cible des matériels nouveaux pour le
recompl complètement et donc ça montre
bien aussi qu'aurait de la situation la
loi de programme ne sera pas
complètement figée comme ce fut le cas
parfois au contraire on reviendra plus
tôt à une genèse évidemment plus
historique néanmoins une fois que j'ai
dit ça il faut garder l'approche de
l'exécution dit à l'europrait parce
qu'au fond malheureusement on avait
quand même habitué dans les années 90 et
2000 à ce que comment dire ces lois de
programme soient sous-exécutées
c'est-à-dire en clair des promesses
plutôt alléchantes des tableaux
capacitaires assez ambitieux et puis
derrière soit parce qu'on jouait avec
euro au courant au reconstant et c'est
bien pour ça d'ailleurs que la
programmation qui vous est proposé elle
est en heure au courant pour cette
raison comme la précédente parce que
elle permet d'intégrer aussi l'inflation
là où jadis rappelez-vous certaines lois
de programmes ont été faites en euros
constance qui était un moyen de faire
comme si il y avait pas d'inflation et
précisément c'est là où on a vu une é du
moyen de donner aux armées quand les
décisions évidemment n'étaient pas
purement et simplement la diminution
l'annulation d'un certain nombre de
commandes sur un certain nombre
d'équipements ou pire peut-être parfois
encore sur l'activité des forces qui se
voit encore moins depuis le Parlement
mais on peut pas dire qu'on est une
armée d'emplois et en même temps
commencer à renier sur l'activité ou sur
l'entraînement des forces ces aléas j'y
reviendrai dans un instant on les
retrouve sur les marges frictionnelles
mais j'en ferai peut-être la
démonstration dans un instant suite à
l'échange que nous aurons cette
souplesse je le redis elle doit
néanmoins se faire toujours avec le
Parlement je dis ce que général de
Gaulle à peine une loi de programmation
promulguée avait décidé lui-même sur une
feuille globalement grande comme
celle-ci du programme nucléaire tactique
Pluton la loi était tout juste
promulguée que le général de Gaulle
lui-même écrasait la loi de programme
sans consulter le Parlement c'était le
général de Gaulle je ne suggère pas de
reprendre ce chemin là pour l'avenir
donc je tenais à le dire évidemment dans
l'entrée de nos de nos discussions
peut-être tout de même un mot puisque la
tentation aussi de d'être complètement
surconcentré sur le capacitaire pourrait
faire oublier aussi une réalité c'est
que une loi de programme c'est
évidemment aussi des questions de
ressources humaines des questions liées
évidemment à la cible en été les
questions liées à la fidélisation les
questions liées aux modèles de
recrutement je sais qu'un certain nombre
de sénateurs sont beaucoup mobilisés je
les en remercie sur le plan famille sur
l'ensemble des sujets qui touchent aussi
à la vie des forces là aussi je
répondrai à vos questions je pense que
c'est une des faiblesses de la LPM en
cours c'est évidemment la difficulté que
nous avons eu collectivement à exécuter
la cible de TP dans la période alors je
me suis intéressé parce qu'aussi un peu
inquiété de cette affaire évidemment
avec les équipes du ministère bon je
trouve que c'est malheureusement un mal
que l'on retrouve dans toutes les armées
des démocraties du monde la difficulté
non pas de recruter mais la difficulté
de fidéliser et regarder évidemment nos
soldats ce qui est vrai des soldats
Évreux aussi pour les civils de la
défense dont on parle trop peu dans les
lois de programme enfin plus de 60 000
civils c'est-à-dire beaucoup plus dans
ce ministère des armées que dans la
plupart des autres ministères civils de
la nation donc là il est clair je
répondrai à vos questions mais
globalement
d'une période précédente ou actuelle en
tout cas en cours où nous étions à une
masse salariale globale de 87 milliards
d'euros pour la période la proposition
que je vous fais est de porter cette
enveloppe globale pour la programmation
à venir à 98 milliards d'euros intégrant
évidemment les cibles telles qu'elles
sont dans le rapport mais aussi
évidemment les revalorisation de points
d'indice mais aussi évidemment la nprm
qui commence à produire des effets et
qui va produire des effets importants
notamment dès le mois d'octobre avec la
prime du combattant terrestre il y a
quelque chose qui va vraiment changer la
vie y compris pour la troupe mais ça
veut dire aussi qu'il y a un chantier
indiciaire notamment pour nos
sous-officiers j'étais avec quelques-uns
sur le terrain récemment on voit bien
que les incitations à quitter le corps
de trou pour devenir sous-officier
accéder au grade de sergent sergent-chef
à Julien chef et quelque chose qui
évidemment se comprime avec le temps en
matière d'intéressement et sur lequel il
faudra évidemment mener non pas une
réflexion mais une action donc la
programmation prévoit des sommes
maintenant évidemment il y a une
réflexion à mener avec les armées
puisque la réflexion indiciaire ne fait
pas la même manière au service de santé
des armées à la DGA ou au sein de
l'armée de terre c'est une évidence
j'enfonce une porte ouverte mais enfin
il y a un travail de sur mesure ou alors
c'est un saupoudrage à l'aveugle et je
garantis déjà que ça ne produira pas des
effets escomptés en tout cas la cible à
275 milles et TP et maintenu ce qui veut
donc dire 6300 créations de postes
beaucoup évidemment sur les métiers
nouveaux sans compter évidemment les
redéploiements aussi parce que je pense
que l'armée de terre va connaître un
moment de modernisation important mais
je pense que le chef d'améliorer
l'occasion de le présenter devant vous
sur aussi la guerre électronique de
demain sur des qualifications nouvelles
pour pour évidemment nous sous-officiers
là encore ce qui renvoie aussi au débat
sur l'intéressement et la fidélisation
plus évidemment les réservistes sur
lequel je me suis déjà exprimé dans de
de nombreux choix devant vous évidemment
les services de renseignement puisque
les thématiques cyberes sont des
thématiques qui suggèrent à la fois de
l'investissement
structurel hard équipement mais enfin
aussi beaucoup de soft et évidemment
beaucoup de ressources humaines et ça
c'est évidemment un point un point
majeur alors 2024 2030
la somme elle est évidemment historique
mais enfin ne le fait pas tout et elle
doit correspondre répondre en tout cas
des enjeux multiples alors en
transparence je l'avais déjà fait devant
vous mais j'assume effectivement le 413
milliards d'euros de besoins de dépenses
militaires pour 400 milliards d'euros de
ressources budgétaires j'ai moi-même vu
qu'effectivement ce que le président
Moscovici avait dit alors il se trouve
que je me suis renseigné aussi depuis le
député muscovici ou le ministre
Moscovici a lui-même voté des lois de
finances ou des lois de programmation
militaires dans lequel il y avait déjà
des marges frictionnelles déjà des
reports de charge le service de santé
des armées existait déjà et produisaient
déjà des et c'est même pire ou mieux je
vous laisse choisir le mot à ces époques
là il y avait aussi beaucoup de ventes
de fonciers militaires et pour cause
donc le ministère des armées a toujours
eu des recettes qui lui sont propres
c'est à dire des recettes affectées et
j'ai même continué de creuser ce sont
souvent les parlementaires qui l'ont
imposé au gouvernement considérant que
il y avait une méfiance de la part de
l'assemblée du Sénat de dire le
ministère des armées va vendre des
bijoux de famille je cite ou des
prestations des ga et c'est ça aussi
beaucoup le service de santé mais la DGA
évidemment aussi facture un certain
nombre de prestations pour les
industriels et plutôt que de voir ces
sommes repartir dans le budget général
de l'État les parlementaires ont
souhaité que ça soit affectés la
nouveauté c'est que moi je souhaitais le
montrer et j'y reviendrai d'ailleurs
aussi sur les tableaux du rapport annexé
dont je mesure pour les parlementaires
qui ne sont pas toujours faciles à
comparer entre les deux périodes on en a
parlé à quelques-uns parce que le
rapport annexé de la LPM en cours parle
de commande ou d'ambition et j'ai
souhaité moi proposer des tableaux dans
lequel on parle de parc c'est-à-dire de
matériel livré et non pas de comment
lancer pourra aussi y revenir dans les
débats mais je pense que c'est important
vu les sommes historiques vu l'effort
qu'on va demander à la nation et
contribuable je pense qu'on doit
effectivement faire ce travail de
précision tant sur le matériel délivré
qu'évidemment sur la manière dont sont
structurés le système de ressources sur
les 13,3 milliards d'euros pour le
sénateur de neige nous avons 7,1
milliards d'euros de recettes en tant
que tel
5,9 milliards d'euros de ressources
extra budgétaires globalement nous nous
appuyons sur les réaliser des périodes
précédentes je pense que dans le
questionnaire il y aura des questions
sur ces sujets on aura l'occasion de de
vous donner évidemment le détail
globalement on est sur une moyenne de
800 millions d'euros par an monsieur le
Président
1,2 milliards d'euros de recomplètement
sur les sessions
pour l'Ukraine je reviendrai peut-être à
la fin jusqu'au en fonction de la nature
du matériel que machine à l'Ukraine ça
nos Billie évidemment pas à au même
système de financement mais ça je
l'expliquerai dans un instant si vous en
êtes d'accord et puis
6,2 milliards d'euros de reports de
charge 1,2 milliards d'euros dont je
rappelle que c'est un des outils aussi
qui nous permet de gérer l'inflation et
ça pour le coup Cigale et la Fourmi
Florence Parly avait fait attention au
report de charge parce que les périodes
étaient évidemment des périodes avec une
inflation particulièrement faible et
donc ça permettait justement d'avoir un
outil plutôt à la baisse on a une
inflation qui augmente et donc je vous
proposerai aussi de se servir des
reports de charge qui sont plutôt bien
vécus pour les raisons que vous imaginez
par les industriels mais qui n'a pas non
plus d'impact majeur pour les finances
publiques et qui nous permet quand même
de traiter cette affaire et les marges
frictionnelles alors ça pour le coup
c'est vu comme Hérode en tout cas si
tentait que Hérode était là en 1960
c'est que évidemment il y a toujours eu
des aléas entre le moment où vous
commandez le moment où vous faites
livrer et donc ces marges frictionnelles
correspondent à ce qui est constaté et
donc là aussi nous avons souhaité le
faire apparaître je le redis devant la
route as ces critères là ont toujours
existé ils ont toujours été dans les
copies ce n'est pas une critique pour me
prédécesseurs mais avez fait le choix de
ne pas le montrer et de le noyer dans
l'enveloppe global moi une fois de plus
je vois le débat monté sur
l'acceptabilité politique et sociétale
des 413 milliards d'euros pour nos
dépenses militaires et donc je juge bon
au regard du moment dans lequel nous
nous trouvons et peut-être aussi du
nombre de contre-vérités ou démagogiques
qu'on peut entendre ici ou là de
détailler le plus possible la
structuration même de la faire ce qui
permet à chacun évidemment de se faire
son opinion et d'y voir clair pourquoi
tant d'argent justement je pense aussi
que ça vaut le coup quand même de se la
poser cette question pour plusieurs
raisons
la première
c'est incontestablement que la
réparation n'est pas terminée et je
pense que c'est vrai sur les
infrastructures si tu devais citer un
exemple dans lequel il y aurait bien de
ventil les munitions mais comme j'y suis
déjà revenu assez longuement lors de la
dernière audition je préfère traiter des
sujets que j'ai peut-être moins traité
de vous précédemment les infrastructures
pour le coup vous êtes nombreux à avoir
été ou être encore élu locaux ce qui est
vrai pour une mairie est vrai pour le
ministère des armées entre le moment où
vous votez vos crédits le moment où vous
lancez les travaux le moment où vous
avez la livraison de ces travaux vous
avez évidemment une inertie qui est très
importante et au fond les marches que
vous avez votées dans la loi de
programme actuel comment ça produire
seulement ses effets et j'étais à Istres
il y a quelques jours vous voyez plein
de grues sur le tarmac de l'aéroport
d'Istres tout simplement parce que là on
est sur des crédits votés souvent en 18
19 20
ou 20 21 et vous voyez évidemment les
travaux se faire par le SD ou par les
entreprises le cas échéant en ce moment
ça veut dire que toute façon la
programmation sur les infras aura une
inertie folle qu'il faudra constater
c'est pour ça qu'en ce moment je suis en
train aussi unité par unité de
territorialiser ce que ça veut dire en
matière d'investissement pour rendre ça
aussi plus lisible pour les armées plus
lisible pour nos concitoyens et aussi le
cas échéant pour les élus locaux
on était globalement je crois 12
milliards d'euros sur les infras dans la
période actuelle et je vous proposerai
une copie de 16 milliards d'euros pour
la comment dire la je vous propose dans
la LPM un poste à 16 milliards d'euros
pour les infrastructures puisque c'est
là où malheureusement
les compressions de budget dans le passé
ont été le plus appliquées avec
désormais un ministère grand
propriétaire de bâtiment qui ne sont pas
toujours dans un bon état je précise
pour les parlementaires qui m'ont saisi
sur les questions de transition
énergétique de passoire énergétique de
rôle des armées évidemment dans la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique que
c'est évidemment sur les infras qu'on
doit un effort majeur puisque c'est là
où nous ne sommes pas du tout exemplaire
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire
deuxième
item dont je suis militant sur lequel il
y a beaucoup d'inertie c'est évidemment
la dissuasion nucléaire je sais que
c'est pas un thème consensuel c'est en
tout cas c'est pas une équipement et une
posture et une doctrine qui est
consensuelle au sein de nos assemblée on
le souhaite que néanmoins le débat
puisse se tenir puisque au fond on vit
là aussi avec une inertie importante sur
les crédits de dissuasion les forces
aériennes stratégiques du moment la
fannule du moment où la fosse du moment
aussi sont le fruit de crédit d'il y a
10 15 ou 20 ans et au fond la
programmation qui vient et la
programmation qui va connaître la
modernisation de notre dissuasion
nucléaire pour les 20 prochaines années
c'est vrai évidemment des vecteurs et
c'est né le 3G
c'est vrai évidemment des missiles
M51 ASN 4G et ça c'est inertie-là va
évidemment être à cheval sur la LPM que
je vous propose notamment
au virage 2030 et dans les années 2030
là on est sur des programmes très
structurants très longs alors l'audition
est retransmise donc évidemment sur la
dissuasion je fais toujours attention à
ce que je dis mais il est clair que on a
le même volume que ce qui avait été
décidé à la fin des années 90 sur la
modernisation des dissuasion sous
laquelle nous vivons actuellement en
matière globalement génération donc ça
c'est un point évidemment clé troisième
chose continuez à restaurer nos
capacités expéditionnelles ça je pense
que le chef est un major des armées vous
l'expliquera dans le détail c'est
évidemment une copie fine qui tient à la
fois à se dire
quelles sont les missions à l'extérieur
du territoire national que l'on souhaite
faire seul ou sur lequel on souhaite
emmener d'autres en notant et hors temps
ce qui ne bille pas complètement
toujours au même logique pareil en
surface maritime et or surface maritime
ce qui pose la question pour le
Saint-Tropez et d'autres évidemment de
ce qui a été fait sur l'Indo Pacifique
parce que là pour le coup on a les
capacités expéditionnaires elles se
branche sur cette logique là plus
évidemment les interactions avec nos
bases prépositionnées et après avec
aussi un équilibre entre qu'est-ce qu'on
doit faire en réactivité entre le moment
où on le présent de la République chef
des armées donne un ordre et qu'est-ce
que l'on doit pouvoir être capable de
faire en endurance une fois qu'on est
parti combien de temps doit-on / peut-on
tenir seul donc ça je pourrais aussi
répondre à vos questions je pense que
dans le rapport annexé pour le coup il y
a une phrase qui est clé c'est le
passage en 2027 sur une capacité
divisionnaire à deux brigades pour
l'armée française complètement équipée
alors quand on le dit comme ça ça veut
dire aussi autant le soutien service de
santé des armées le SCA la
scorpionisation la défense solaire
autour de la de la division et de
repartir non pas de morceaux mais
vraiment d'un effet militaire complet et
en cela ça nous met dans un club de pays
au sein de le temps en tout cas de peu
de pays qui sont capables de le faire je
le dis avec prudence et diplomatie pour
éviter de vexer qui que ce soit mais
enfin en clair aujourd'hui avec les
États-Unis qui sont capables de le faire
bon donc et là nous en restaurant ces
capacités là on se remet évidemment dans
un rôle notamment pour la sécurité
européenne qui est complètement
différent et bien je pourrais aussi
répondre à vos questions troisième des
choses je les avais plutôt de largement
développé devant vous mais je l'ai reçu
ce sont évidemment tous les espaces qui
se militarisent
et ou dans lequel il y a un saut
technologique important et qui peuvent
en plus parfois contourner la dissuasion
nucléaire alors là évidemment c'est la
question du cyber
sujet majeur sur lequel l'aventure ne
fait que commencer maintenant aussi
beurre on peut y accoler la question du
quantique la question de l'intelligence
artificielle là aussi le DG pour
répondre aussi à vos questions quand
vous le disionnerez de manière précise
sur ces sujets sur lequel il faut y
mettre beaucoup de moyens et là c'est
une affaire de souveraineté c'est comme
si l'égalisent dans les années 60 avait
dit l'atome n'est pas pour nous bon
l'atome militaire donc là il est clair
qu'il y a un axe d'effort important qui
coûte de l'argent le spatial dans lequel
on a une militarisation évidemment de
l'espace qui est majeur avec un
durcissement qui est clé là aussi
évidemment des propositions sont faites
en la matière les fonds sous-marins on
voit bien que là aussi la capacité à
sécuriser nos fonds sous-marins
en français
câble sous-marin guerre des mines y
compris dans un Atlantique qui devient
de plus en plus dangereux et pas que la
mer Méditerranée là on voit bien qu'on a
aussi des durcissements importants qui
nécessitent à la fois des sauts
technologiques et aussi d'occuper des
segments qui n'étaient pas occupables
jusqu'à présent parce que non
méditarisés quand on met tout ça bout à
bout ça explique aussi ce pourquoi on a
des crédits qui évidemment augmentent
j'y rajouterais aussi un élément mais je
ne doute pas qu'on y reviendra
longuement c'est aussi le point
d'équilibre entre la cohérence de
l'ensemble et la masse ça c'est un point
qui est un point délicat sur lequel il
nous a fallu trouver un équilibre je
pense que l'équilibre fera toujours
l'objet d'un débat je le mesure bien cet
équilibre il a été construit par les
états majors avec une vraiment une une
direction qui a été donnée par le séma
validé par le Président de la République
et se dire au fond c'est le syndrome
hélicoptère
avoir des cibles d'hélicoptères qui sont
satisfaisantes sur le papier mais dont
on sait très bien qu'ils ne décolle pas
ne décolle pas parce que le MCO n'est
pas au rendez-vous ne décolle pas ce que
les pièces détachées sont pas là décolle
pas parce que la formation n'est pas au
rendez-vous parce que les équipages ne
sont pas toujours là où les
infrastructures terrestres d'accueil de
l'équipement en question ne sont pas là
donc là c'est évidemment l'enjeu de
quand on avance sur cet LPM là la
question se posait pas trop on démarrait
la scorpionisation donc au fond fallait
lancer l'affaire désormais le tout
nettoyant pas que d'avoir le griffon
livré mais d'avoir aussi
l'infrastructure de parking qui va avec
plus le système Sikes quel système le
soft d'interconnexion qui est bien
présent dans le griffon en question plus
évidemment nos soldats qui sont formés
autour et le MCO qui va en face et donc
là aussi dans les débats j'essaierai de
d'y revenir mais la proposition qui est
faite c'est aussi parfois de remettre en
cohérence et de s'assurer que on est
bien des livraisons qui correspondent
aussi à ce qu'on est capable de faire en
matière d'activité opérationnelle et on
revient à mon affaire de division et de
brigade en 2027 ce qu'il nous faut nous
c'est regarder un effet militaire réel
je le dis aussi tranquillement
la difficulté que j'ai aussi comme
ministre de tutelle de la BTD c'est que
les armées réclament de la cohérence là
où évidemment les industriels préfèrent
la masse et donc pour des raisons qu'on
peut comprendre et qui sont éminemment
louables mais sur lequel il nous faut
trouver un équilibre et là pour le coup
les questionnaires aussi parce que ces
questions sont redoutablement complexes
techniquesment mais item par item nous
permettra aussi peut-être de vous donner
des informations précises qui
expliqueront aussi comment en miroir on
a on a cherché justement à faire ses
choix de mise en cohérence et je le dis
tout de suite il n'y a pas de rupture de
cible rupture de cible ça veut dire
qu'on a compris mais que c'est fini en
revanche on a des sites qui vont
dépasser 2030 ça
vous m'avez toujours invité à le faire
carte sur table donc je le dis ici
devant vous monsieur le Président Madame
il est clair que alors que on parlait
d'horizon d'ambition parment
opérationnelle 2030 dans LPM en cours
on va désormais parler en matériel
livrer en parc et avec en face le souci
de la cohérence qui va bien MCO pièces
détachées formation etc et ça évidemment
on pourra le décrire pour avancer et
conclure mon propos les marches et les
trajectoires parce que je sais que c'est
un débat évidemment qui va intéresser
beaucoup vous l'avez dit vous-même
monsieur le Président je vous en
remercie 32 milliards d'euros budget
annuel de la défense en 2017 en 2027 56
milliards d'euros dans la proposition
qui vous est faite dans ce projet de loi
en 2030 69 milliards d'euros
dans cette proposition globalement deux
tiers du chemin aura été fait sous les
deux quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron alors
parfois ici ou là pareil dans la presse
j'ai entendu quelques remarques un peu
curieuses en mode mais pourquoi il y
aura encore du chemin à faire entre 27
et 30 bon bah déjà parce que la
programmation j'y peux rien va toi 27 et
30 et puis si certains ne font pas
confiance en leur futur candidats avec
son présidentielle pour continuer
l'effort ça j'y peux rien je le dis sans
ma liste mais enfin je le dis devant une
chambre qui est toujours soutenue les
efforts des armées en tout cas c'est 10
ou 15 dernières années donc il est clair
que oui un choix politique à faire et on
pourra mettre toutes les prévenances du
monde au bout d'un moment quand il y a
une élection présidentielle quand il y a
une élection législative je déplore
qu'on parle pas assez de ces sujets
enfin c'est dommage parce que ça va
peut-être permis d'éclairer un certain
nombre de concitoyens sur des sujets
aussi clés que nous ayons militaires les
dissuasion nucléaires ou les
exportations d'armes enfin il est clair
qu'il y a un choix politique aussi en 27
qu'il faudra soit confirmer ou non
puisque ce qu'une loi a fait notre loi
peut le défaire et ça je l'assume bien
deuxième des choses sur les marches
il y a aussi une réalité il y a des
choix politiques qui tiennent à
l'équilibre des finances publiques que
la commission des finances de cette
maison évidemment est très attachée il
est clair que la trajectoire qui vous
est proposé correspond à la trajectoire
que Bruno Le Maire et Gabriel Attal
proposeront au Sénat dans le cadre de la
programmation des finances publiques
sinon évidemment les deux projets de loi
ne seraient pas compatibles et ça serait
un sincère première élément et deuxième
élément ce que je ne suis pas ministre
du budget mais que néanmoins je suis le
dépensier comme ordonnateur les marches
tiennent compte aussi de réalité qui
sont parfois physiques
typiquement sur le porte-avions de
nouvelle génération sur le SN et le 3G
sur certains programmes spatiaux sur
certains certaines missions liées à la
dissuasion nucléaire comme je vous le
disais vous avez parfois des besoins
physiques en crédit de paiement qui se
retrouveront quoi qu'il arrive entre 27
et 30 et qui vous socle quoi qu'il
arrive un certain nombre de dépenses
j'ai vu des amendements arriver à
l'Assemblée nationale avec des marches à
400 millions d'euros au 28 ou 400
millions d'euros en 29 avec une démarche
qui peuvent être à 7 ou 8 milliards
d'euros là en 2024 25 non enfin je pour
le coup c'est mon devoir de le dire au
parlementaire il y a quand même des
réalités qui tient la vie des programmes
on y peut rien qui s'impose et qui vous
stocke une partie de vos marches et
après vous avez ce qui enlève du choix
politique mais toute la marque n'est pas
qu'une affaire de choix politique il y a
aussi une réalité physique qui tient au
crédit de paiement du des grands
matériels des grands équipements que
vous souhaitez financer là aussi ça
tombe sous le sens mais c'est quand même
mieux de le dire je vous rassure sur le
porte-avion monsieur le président
5 milliards d'euros dans la période pour
le PNG de coût pour les industriels
chantiers technicatom naval group pour
faire vite
après en sous-traitance 5 milliards
d'euros de crédit de paiement dans la
dans la copie ce que je demande juste
aux industriels c'est on soit aussi
comme dans n'importe quel
contractualisation c'est que les crédits
de paiement arrivent au fur et à mesure
aussi que les travaux sont réalisés et
comme il y a beaucoup de trésorerie dans
ces entreprises qui parfois
appartiennent à l'État ce n'est pas un
effort qui les met en danger ou un sans
faut là aussi dans les questionnaires on
pourra documenter cette affaire là mais
c'est de se dire que à l'exportation il
ne demanderait pas forcément est-ce que
tout soit payé avant même que le bateau
ait commencé sa construction pour dire
les choses un peu un peu trivialement
donc oui il y a c'est pas un effort
c'est aussi une pratique que je saute
aussi de plus en plus installée qui est
de créer une scène tension entre la
trésorerie d'un côté les crédits de
paiement du contribuable de l'autre
parce que c'est ce qui permet aussi de
conserver une musculature une agilité
aussi de notre bit d par ailleurs
j'en terminerai peut-être par
l'inflation
puisque c'est un sujet évidemment dont
on parle beaucoup alors c'est un sujet
dont on parle beaucoup mais il m'arrive
aussi de m'étonner qu'on en parle autant
je m'explique pourquoi puisque déjà j'ai
la chance d'être à la tête du seul
ministère dans la République qui dispose
d'autant d'outils pour gérer l'inflation
et que dans mes souvenirs on ne pose
jamais la question comment le ministre
de l'Intérieur le ministre de la justice
va gérer la construction de ces
commissariats et ses prisons en fonction
de la flation ils n'ont ni report de
charge ni article de solidarité
interministérielle pour leur carburant
ni revoyure en général facile pour avoir
des crédits de paiement nouveaux en
collectif budgétaire donc je le dis
juste déjà le ministère des armées et
j'y suis pour rien c'est souvent le
Parlement d'ailleurs qu'il a imposé au
gouvernement dans les années précédent
parce que c'est pas la première fois
qu'elle l'inflation c'est-à-dire il doit
y avoir des mécanismes qui ne doivent
pas entraver la programmation d'autres y
ont pensé avant nous et donc dans le
projet de loi tel qu'il vous est
présenté pour prendre un exemple le
fameux article 5 sur les carburants
opérationnels quelque chose de bien
connu vous est proposé de nouveau
c'était pas automatique puisque déjà
vous-même vous l'aviez imposé en 2018
dans le cas de la discussion budgétaire
c'est un bon exemple les reports de
charge sont un autre bon exemple
effectivement cette inflation elle est
estimée mais il faut être prudent sur
les estimations vous l'avez dit
vous-même parce que les critères peuvent
varier à 30 milliards d'euros sur
l'ensemble de la période moi je vais
aussi vous présenter les choses de la
manière suivante dans les lois de
programme depuis les années 60 il y a eu
deux manières de les regarder
soit c'est la courbe budgétaire et les
critères économiques et financiers qui
font le physique le matériel
d'entraînement la vie des troupes
soit c'est la promesse du physique
le rapport annexé l'engagement du
ministre devant le Parlement qui fait
les ressources en fait est-ce qu'on
considère que les marches sont des
planchers ou des plafonds mais ça c'est
important peut-être d'ailleurs que ça
appellera des
débats aussi ou amendements que sais-je
sur cette affaire là nous au moment où
je vous présente ce projet de loi
monsieur le Président Monsieur sénateur
il est clair que pour nous ce ne sont
pas des plafonds se sont forcément des
planchers sous lequel on ne doit pas
aller j'en veux pour prendre preuve le
milliard d'euros que nous avons proposé
de voter je vous en remercie l'année
dernière pour
des crédits de défense c'est-à-dire en
fait qu'on dit qu'elle est exécutée
exécutée à l'euro près cette
programmation actuellement en fait c'est
faux puisque en fait elle est
surexécutée déjà d'un milliard d'euros
et je vous proposerai un collectif
budgétaire on peut aller faire 1,5
milliards d'euros supplémentaires je me
suis déjà expliqué devant vous l'uth
antidrone quelques effets d'inflation
des gros efforts sur les munitions et
donc on voit bien qu'on va vers une LPM
qui aura été sur exécuté de 2,5
milliards d'euros par rapport à ce qui
était programmé je dis pas ça pour qu'on
nous en remercie je dis juste que je
veux qu'on nous crédite de bonnes foi de
cette acceptation que les marches sont
des socles des planchers et non pas des
plafonds et ça veut dire qu'en 20223 là
en ce moment en dépit de l'inflation
très puissante et grave que nous
connaissons sur la pour le pays vous
n'avez aucun programme aucun équipement
militaire qui a pris du retard grâce
notamment à l'argent aussi qui a été
évidemment voté dans le cadre des
voitures rectificatives ou de discussion
que nous avons évidemment avec les
différents
industriels
peut-être un dernier mot sur l'aide à
l'Ukraine puisque je m'étais engagé
auprès de vous à ce que évidemment on
soit bien hors programmation et
peut-être vous donner les la manière
dont c'était à l'Ukraine va faire
l'objet d'un financement différencié en
fonction de de la qualité du matériel je
pense qu'il y a quand même un enjeu de
transparence aussi et de crédibilité
bilité premier type de matériel un
matériel très vieux qui n'était plus
dans le format de nos armées et que nous
avons donné à l'Ukraine je donne un
exemple le TRF1 nos vieilles pièces
d'artillerie qui étaient tractées
évidemment là il n'y a pas lieu de de se
faire financer une pièce qui était
remisée dans des camps militaires et
dont nous n'aurions plus jamais eu
évidemment l'utilité deuxième catégorie
de matériel ce sont des matériels
vieillissants mais encore dans le format
des armées
dont nous avons prévu de les retirer
soit dans LPM qui vient soit au début de
celle d'après pause 2030 mais dont on a
décidé d'avancer le retrait pour les
donner à l'Ukraine les crottes bon
exemple matériel qui est encore très
efficace et moins qu'on puisse dire les
Ukrainiens même le disent bah on peut
pas nier qu'on enlève du matériel à nos
armées les crottes sont enlevés mais en
même temps je serai malhonnête aussi si
je vous disais pas qu'on les a retirés
dans la période quoi qu'il arrive au
bénéfice de matériel neufs en espèces
level Mika et donc là pour le coup c'est
là où vous retrouvez le 1,2 milliards
dans les 13 milliards c'est de se dire
on est bien dans le format des armées on
les aurait retiré sauf qu'on les retire
plus vite et donc ils sont dans la 413
milliards puisque c'est du matériel
ancien qui s'en va au bénéfice d'un
matériel neuf pour nos armées troisième
catégorie de matériel du matériel neuf
les Césars mieux connu là pour le coup
on est en dehors des 413 milliards
d'euros parce que pour le coup on prend
un matériel neuf des armées et on le
recomplète par un autre matériel neuf là
pour le coup
pas lieu de le mettre dans la
programmation et donc c'est cette
transparence budgétaire que je vous
propose en fonction des trois catégories
que je viens de vous proposer matériel
ancien dont on ne se servait plus aucune
raison de le financer ça serait
malhonnête matériel qu'on s'apprêtait à
retirer au fond on le donne à l'Ukraine
donc on fait un changement avec le
matériel neuf plus vite que prévu on le
met dans les 413 en tout cas pour le 1,2
milliards à date tel que c'est prévu et
le troisième type de matériel le
matériel neuf pour du matériel neuf
évidemment on est en dehors de la
programmation et donc la parole que je
vous avais donnée me semble-t-il avec ce
mécanisme est ainsi respecter j'étais
affreusement long mais j'ai essayé en
dès l'entrée de jeu de répondre au
maximum de questions que vous aviez
pointé dans votre dans votre propos
initial renseignement je pourrais aussi
y répondre si vous le souhaitez mais je
vais peut-être laisser les rapporteurs
le cas échéant prendre la parole
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
ministre pour cette présentation je vous
propose une méthode un petit peu plus
dynamique que ce à quoi nous avons
l'habitude généralement c'est à dire que
après chaque rapport vous de telle sorte
que les réponses puissent être puissent
être précises est-ce que le rapporteur
de la commission des finances veut bien
nous entretenir de ces interrogations
budgétaires merci monsieur le Président
et merci de me convier à cette audition
monsieur le ministre je laisserai le
soin à mes collègues de la commission
compétente au fond de vous poser les
questions qui ont du stress à la
programmation militaire et à ces enjeux
je me concentrerai uniquement sur les
aspects budgétaires le président Cambon
l'a évoqué dans son propos luminaire
lorsque nous avons reçu le Haut Conseil
des finances publiques nous sommes
convenus du constat suivant c'est qu'à
force de multiplier les lois de
programmation ce qui est plutôt
sympathique si on les prend
individuellement mais l'édition finit
par venir en contradiction avec un autre
objectif que rappelait pas plus tard
faire votre collègue Attal devant la
commission des finances il faut diminuer
la dépense publique et il faut ramener
en 2027 en dessous de 3% le déficit de
la France
et on discutera je crois tout à l'heure
en séance du pack de stabilité on voit
bien que là il y a une contradiction une
difficulté le deuxième élément sur
lequel je voulais appeler votre
attention vous n'y êtes pour rien mais
enfin quand on parle de souveraineté de
stratégie en matière de souveraineté il
faut quand même pas perdre de vue que
aujourd'hui la charge de la dette est
plus importante que le budget que nous
consacrons à notre défense et que
lorsqu'on parle d'autonomie le déficit
du commerce extérieur et trois fois et
demi
volume le budget de la défense donc
c'est pas pour noircir le tableau mais
je pense qu'il faut que nous prenions
tous conscience que cette souveraineté
dont nous nous réclamons tous et que
nous voulons pour notre pays
doit s'inscrire dans le contexte
économique que je viens de rappeler cela
étant dit
je voudrais revenir sur la question de
l'inflation vous avez dit que sur la
période
[Musique]
et c'est un sujet qui est devant nous
parce que sur les lois de programmation
intérieure et notamment sur celles sous
le régime du quai de laquelle nous
vivons nous n'avons pas d'inflation où
nous n'avions pas d'inflation c'est donc
un élément nouveau qui vient perturber
cette programmation et tant qu'on est
sur l'inflation si vous pouviez nous en
dire un tout petit peu plus sur le
milliard et demi de 2023 parce que hier
monsieur Attal nous a dit ni projet de
budget modificatif ni décret d'avance
donc c'est pas très très bien comment on
va pouvoir les faire rentrer dans le
budget et dernier point je note avec
satisfaction un effort important sur le
MCO est-ce que il s'agit d'une mise à
niveau du MCO pour tenir
compte pardon durant chérissement des
équipements ou est-ce qu'il s'agit
plutôt et d'une amélioration de la
disponibilité technique opérationnel
parce que de ce point de vue il y a
certainement des marges de manœuvre mais
il faut peut-être pas afficher des
objectifs trop ambitieux parce que ce
qu'on a pu afficher par le passé nous ne
les avons pas forcément tenu voilà
monsieur le Président je veux pas dire
plus parce que vous avez la gentillesse
de ma vie ce serait mal venu que je
monopolise la parole mais je pleins
d'autres questions que je regarde pour
d'autres auditions parfait non non mais
c'est la présence de la commission des
finances c'est tout à fait essentielle
parce que face à une somme pareille la
dimension budgétaire n'est pas neutre
sur le ministre voulez-vous bien
plusieurs choses bon déjà moi je je suis
très sensible parce que vous dites sur
la souveraineté parce que les efforts
que nous faisons en matière de sécurité
enfin de souveraineté de sécurité non
pas de sens évidemment on fragilise par
ailleurs d'autres éléments aussi
essentiels que notre crédibilité sur les
marchés financiers notre capacité à ne
pas reporter sur les générations futures
des efforts qui ne seraient pas en
situation de pouvoir rembourser et je
pense que c'est bien de de le redire
d'autant plus que ça nous ramènera aussi
au débat sur les marches parce que
exécuter une loi de programme à l'euro
près c'est une chose l'exécuter à l'euro
près quand ça augmente son est une autre
et la soutenabilité évidemment de cette
augmentation elle était elle est clé et
donc au fond la progressivité permet
aussi évidemment d'être en adéquation
avec la stratégie de finance publique
telle qu'elle est proposée par ailleurs
par les ministres de Bercy
deuxième des choses les lois de
programme permettent quand même malgré
tout de limiter des à-coups de dépenses
moi j'en suis intimement persuadé pour
le ministère des armées pour mettre
aussi penché sur le programme
précédentes c'est sûr que tout d'un coup
on a les 413 milliards d'euros qui
arrivent enfin sauf pépin majeur qui
serait lié malheureusement à l'activité
opérationnelle je touche du bois en
clair les Opex et l'engagement des
forces mais ça malheureusement c'est un
autre débat au fond on a quand même on
crée de la prévisibilité qui nous permet
quand même de maintenir un certain
nombre de structures de coûts ce qui
m'amène à votre question sur le MCO en
fait c'est les deux à la fois on
améliore la disponibilité des matériels
cohérence versus masse c'est ce que je
décrivais tout à l'heure pour le coup on
a des chiffres qui sont importants en
termes de disponibilités qui ont
augmenté parfois de 15 de 20 points de
pourcentage sur la période de la LPM en
cours ça c'est évidemment une bonne
nouvelle mais on a aussi un effort à
faire avec la verticalisation des
contrats en matière de MCO au fond
entrant le bon point d'équilibre qu'on
est un MCO qui augmente beaucoup sur du
matériel qui vieillit ça tombe un peu
sous le sens que vous ayez du MCO qui
soit parfois très important sur du
matériel
qui a parfois deux ou trois années ça
pose évidemment des questions et ça
c'est aussi une question qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à affiner dans les années
qui viendront avec les industriels parce
que ça dépend aussi beaucoup notre
stratégie l'exportation si je prends
l'exemple des avions le F-35 américain
est un avion qui apparaît comme plutôt
meilleur marché à l'achat mais dont le
MC au derrière s'avère être bougrement
salé pour les différents clients là où
Dassault a trouvé un équilibre entre
l'acquisition initiale et le MCO pour
ses avions donc il est clair que la
question du maintien en condition
opérationnel c'est une question qu'on a
évidemment beaucoup de documenté dans le
cadre de la loi de programme qui permet
d'augmenter la disponibilité à coup sûr
entre d'ailleurs le MCO le petit MCO
réalisé en interne par les armées et le
gros MCO en tout cas le MCO
intermédiaire qui est réalisé par les
différents industriels notamment aussi
dans des industries qui sont au plus
proche des différentes forces sur les
bases aériennes sur les bases navales et
bien sûr dans les dans les dans les
régiments sur l'inflation
deux trois commentaires le carburant
n'est pas tout mais il a longtemps été
quand même le grand défi donc je
l'ensemble des produits pétroliers du
ministère représentent tout de même des
sommes importantes et si le Parlement a
souhaité justement ces dispositifs c'est
parce que précisément parfois il y avait
des difficultés de bouclage et pour le
coup c'est quand même un des moyens
évidemment qui nous permettrait de
traiter l'affaire donc ça je vous le
redis c'est important quand même pour le
ministère des armées en gestion en
pratique de pouvoir traiter la question
des carburants
de quand l'inflation est négative ou
quand elle n'existe pas la tentation
c'est de réaliser ce qu'on appelle du
bourrage c'est à dire en clair de lancer
des équipements ou des programmes qui
n'étaient pas prévus dans la
programmation je pense qu'il faut
essayer de s'en prémunir à l'avenir
parce que on le voit bien là on a une
programmation qui est imaginée avec des
critères qui sont par définition
dégradées ça veut dire que si d'ici à
2030 et je l'espère on avait un
renversement de tendance on récupérait
énormément des anses je pense qu'il faut
pour le coup être plus prudent à
l'avenir quand on récupère de l'aisance
et je le vois on a des programmes qui
ont été lancés pour de bonnes raisons
sur le spatial le fort neuve de
Vincennes pour la
dgments cyber pour donner des exemples
précis qui n'étaient pas dans la
programmation initiale mais qui
évidemment quand l'inflexion augmente
vous avez une compression qui se fait
dans nos budgets ce qui explique le
milliard d'euros l'année dernière aussi
qui a permis de faire la jonction entre
les deux et le PM sur cette affaire là
donc ça c'est évidemment un point clé
pour le milliard 5 moi c'est une
autorisation que j'ai reçu de Matignon
pour construire la maquette budgétaire
après je ne suis pas dans le secret des
calendriers des différents PLF ou
collectifs budgétaires donc je pourrais
revenir vers vous le cas échéant après
un échange avec Matignon et Bercy mais
en tout cas pour évidemment faire les
informations qui vont bien vous donner
pendant les informations qui vont bien
en la matière sur les critères
pardonnez-moi qui ont permis de
construire les indices d'inflation ce
sont ceux qui sont fournis par Bercy
ils ne sont pas que sur la consommation
on a une toute une batterie d'indices
sur des critères particuliers matières
premières et compris sur des matériaux
particuliers industriels donc là aussi
je pense que ça vaut le coup peut-être
de vous communiquer la manière dont tu
as été construite justement les
prévisions d'inflation et aussi
d'ailleurs sur les périodes puisque des
chiffres ont pu circuler au dessus de 30
milliards mais qui prenaient des années
qui étaient hors LPM auparavant donc au
bout d'un moment on a des choses qui se
qui se perturbe un peu je l'inflation
est un défi mais je considère qu'elle ne
nous entrave pas dans la manière au
moment où je vous parle de la manière
d'exécuter la programmation en tout cas
il y a d'autres ministères qui à mon
avis sont bien plus inquiets sur les
effets d'inflation que celui des armées
en ce moment où je vous parle après
évidemment faut le documenter il faut le
regarder je pense que sur certaines
matières premières pour le coup pour nos
industriels c'est un enjeu critique
qu'il faut surveiller très près alors on
s'intéresse
merci bien
alors
on va commencer par le programme 146
équipement des forces avec deux
rapporteurs qui vont s'exprimer la
réponse du ministre suivra
Cédric Perrin puis Hélène Conway
allons-y merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre j'aimerais d'abord
que vous reveniez plus précisément que
vous ne l'avez fait sur le tableau des
capacités qui figurant un ex du projet
de la programmation militaire vous
affirmez que cette cote programmation
militaire va irriguer l'industrie et les
territoires c'est un peu l'objectif de
votre tournée des régiments et des
régions en ce moment
peut-être mais sans doute pas autant que
le prévoyait la LP actuelle puisque de
nombreux programmes subissent en effet à
minima ce que vous appelez des étalement
c'est le cas notablement du programme
scorpion la cible griffon baisse de 30%
de même que la cible Jaguar et Serval la
cible des chars Leclerc rénovée passe de
200 à 160
160 chars de combat c'est très peu et
nous avons montré dans un rapport de la
commission très récent que les
enseignements sur les enseignements de
la guerre en Ukraine ce que cela
signifiait l'un des rares programmes
annoncé en hausse dans cette LP porte
sur le système de drone tactique pas
trop leur il s'agirait en fait d'une
grosse erreur d'une confusion
semble-t-il entre drone et système
puisque on resterait en réalité à 5
systèmes et non 17 comme indiqué dans le
tableau capacitaire ce qui fait je le
rappelle pour un système de 5 drones 25
drones plus éventuellement trois drones
d'entraînement au lieu des 85 annoncé
dans la loi de programmation militaire
puisque 17 x 5 ça nous amenait à 85 des
erreurs sont évidemment possibles mais
il y a néanmoins de quoi s'étonner qu'il
est alors la stratégie en matière de
drone quels seront les drones achetés ou
développés avec les moyens mis en oeuvre
ou en étant des appels d'offres colibris
et larinae alors que les industriels ont
investi dans ces programmes mais que les
perspectives sont plutôt floues sur
l'avenir puisqu'il semblerait là aussi
qu'il y a eu une erreur dans leur
rédaction du marché d'appel d'offre qui
ne soit potentiellement nécessaire de
repasser un marché d'appel d'offre
européen ce qui serait évidemment assez
catastrophique pour ce programme qui
était plutôt très bien parti
certains programmes sont purement et
simplement oubliés par le rapport annexé
je pense notamment au programme des vbae
qui doit succéder au VBL ou encore à
l'engin du génie de combat je pense
aussi au remplacement des poids lourds
de l'armée de terre la précédente LPM
mentionnée un successeur pour les
véhicules cassis qui ici a disparu la
question de la logistique et on le sait
tous très bien et fondamental quand un
régiment d'infanterie ne dispose que
d'un seul camion de dépannage ça pose
quand même quelques problèmes quant au
tigre marque 3 il n'est pas mentionné
non plus il a fait état de 67
hélicoptères mais combien seront rénovés
là aussi monsieur le ministre nous
aimerions des précisions exactes sur le
mach 3 ou Mac 2 plus
c'est un sujet évidemment extrêmement
important pour nos armées mais aussi
pour l'industriel la réduction des
cibles sur le Rafale de 185 à 137 et sur
les mirages 2000 dénonés nous préoccupe
également une partie des rafales est
mobilisée pour la dissuasion tout le
monde le sait et que peut-on espérer
d'un format aussi restreint où en est-on
du
tout rafale annoncé par le président de
la République pardon à Mont-de-Marsan de
façon générale le nouveau tableau
capacitaire que vous proposez monsieur
le ministre est difficilement comparable
avec le précédent et ses regrettable et
je le confirme malgré ce que vous venez
de dire puisque ce que vous dites est
faux dans le précédent le PM il était
question de tableau avec les ambitions
et le parc aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus
que le parc et d'ailleurs c'est encore
plus compliqué à comprendre puisque le
matériel diffère il y a parfois des
redécoupements et même parfois des
regroupements un exemple flagrant et
celui du serval
monsieur le ministre la frontière entre
alien industrielle et arbitrage
budgétaire n'est pas clair je
souhaiterais que vous soyez beaucoup
plus précis sur les raisons de l'écart
entre un effort financier de 400
milliards d'euros qui est une enveloppe
évidemment conséquente et la réalité des
évolutions capacitaires à 2030 pourquoi
la liste des programmes en recul
est-elle si longue pouvez-vous nous
expliquer ces choix les principaux
arbitrages effectués en amont de cet LPM
et que dont nous n'avons évidemment pas
eu connaissance monsieur le ministre
pour terminer il y a des renoncements
qui s'incarnent dans des étalement
faisant de l'économie de guerre un
concept plus parfois une réalité avec un
budget en hausse de 40% expliquer le
paradoxe des réductions de cible est un
défi mais vous êtes parfaitement habile
pour le faire donc vous allez pouvoir
peut-être nous expliquer expliciter
davantage ce que je viens de vous
demander merci merci alors Hélène Conway
deuxième reporter et puis après une
réponse c'est toujours sur le même
pardon
non non mais je fais rapport par rapport
à ça on va plus s'en sortir
d'abord je voudrais rendre hommage en
effet comme vous l'avez fait au
personnel à la fois diplomatique et
militaire notamment après positionné à
Djibouti en facilité l'évacuation avec
succès de 5308 personnes dont 209
français alors Monsieur le Ministre
financière de cette LPM est conséquente
mais un budget ne fait pas une vision
alors que veut-on faire de cette
enveloppe c'est la question je crois à
laquelle la revue nationale stratégique
se devait de répondre ce qu'elle a fait
de façon plutôt incomplète peut-être
parce que rédiger trop rapidement
je crois qu'il nous manque un exercice
de type livre blanc pour fonder la
légitimité de cette LPM lui donner une
vision partagée expliquée les formats
les priorités et donc les choix
effectués en matière d'équipement
militaire aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas
évident alors vous avez parlé de pivot
adaptable mouvant c'est bien mais
peut-être que un cap très clairement
défini serait mieux alors je souhaite
vous poser une question en lien avec la
coopération européenne notamment
franco-allemande et puis je vous
demanderai de préciser et de clarifier
trois points suivants cette coopération
est au cœur de plusieurs programmes
structurant pour notre modèle d'armée
mais qui semble aujourd'hui fragile le
rapport annexé au projet de LPM
mentionne rapidement le projet de
système principal de combat terrestre le
mgcs
mais en l'état actuel ce programme
fondamental est en panne l'échéance de
2035 ne paraît plus guerre crédible au
même moment la guerre en Ukraine rebat
les cartes dans le domaine des
industries terrestres l'industrie
sud-coréenne très réactive et largement
sollicité en Pologne nous devrions
peut-être nous inspirer de cette
réactivité reine métal promeut son
charpentaire il apparaît clairement que
l'industrie terrestre allemande veut
affirmer son leadership Nexter promeux
pour sa part le MBT les voies d'une
convergence semblent étroites où en sont
vos discussions avec votre homologue
allemand et d'autres coopérations
sont-elles possibles deuxième volet de
cette coopération européenne la 400m
programme qui est l'objet d'un étalement
en LPM puisque la cible est d'au moins
35 en 2030 contre 53 dans le cadre
actuel cet appareil d'autant plus
nécessaire que la fermeture des bases en
Afrique nécessitera de pouvoir se
déployer
rapidement sur de longues distances il
semble que la cadence actuelle mettrait
en danger la chaîne de production de
l'appareil à compter de 2026 la relation
franco-allemande est là aussi en
question puisque l'Allemagne bloquerait
des licences à l'exportation pouvez-vous
nous confirmer ces informations les
commandes de l'Espagne et du Royaume-Uni
sont aussi dans la balance une
négociation dans un cadre européen et
donc nécessaire monsieur le ministre
quels sont les pistes que vous envisagez
à ce sujet et je vous demanderai une
clarification sur trois points d'abord
les forces terrestres le texte prévoit
200 chars de combat rénovés en 2035 y
a-t-il une programmation pour les
véhicules blindés légers qui permettent
d'assurer les missions dans
l'environnement du Charles clair
deuxième point de clarification la
flotte de surface pourquoi avoir
repousser les bâtiments ravitailleurs de
force BRF la présente LPM fixée un
objectif de 4 PRF dont les livraisons
devaient s'étaler entre 2022 et 2029
celui-ci est-il repoussé à 2035 et pour
quelle raison alors que la région
Indo-Pacifique et vous l'avez rappelé
semble être considéré comme une zone
prioritaire pour la défense et la
sécurité de notre pays troisième point
dans le même ordre d'idée qu'est-ce qui
a présidé au décalage dans le temps de
la livraison des 169 hélicoptères
intermé léger je vous remercie
voilà première série de questions
précises merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci beaucoup
et après ce que la sinon évidemment il
ne faut pratiquement une heure pour
revenir sur l'ensemble des des choix qui
ont pu être faits bon première des
choses même est-ce que le livre blanc
fond d'une légitimité
voilà président Cambon a dit en
introduction que il revenait au
Parlement justement de donner la
légitimité aux travaux préparatoires du
DPM parce que d'ailleurs vous avez fait
vous même avec votre méthodologie propre
les groupes de travail ont permis
c'était aussi une forme de construction
quand même avec l'ensemble des signes
tanks avec l'ensemble des associations
et puis bon les signes tank dans le
passé ont quand même plutôt servi à
diminuer les moyens budgétaires et
essayer justement de trouver une
légitimité à la diminution des crédits
budgétaires c'est quand même une réalité
c'est comme ça que dans les forces
armées le mot livre blanc résonne
toujours en tout cas là où je souscris
complètement à ce que vous dites c'est
que le budget n'est pas une vision et
d'ailleurs au passage le tableau
capacitaire ce qui va me permettre de
faire aussi une réponse déjà un peu
globale ne traduit pas non plus une
vision en tant que tel militaire je
pense que c'est en fonction des missions
que l'on souhaite donner à nos forces
armées en fonction des menaces
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés que
nous devons bâtir justement ce tableau
ou alors à considérer que ce n'est que
de la commande publique militaire pour
des industriels c'est un autre une autre
approche évidemment la loi de
programmation militaire elle existe
notre souveraineté est importante le
maintien de l'emploi dans nos
territoires le son j'aimerais dans un
instant mais au fond ce qui ce qui va
quand même malgré tout compter c'est la
cohérence et ça moi j'en serais le
défenseur puisque on a trop payé
justement dans le passé des cibles je le
disais d'hélicoptère par exemple dans
lequel on n'était pas capable de les
faire décoller pareil pour un certain
nombre d'équipements terrestres et
objectivement vous ne pouviez vous en
savez quelque chose parce que en général
vous déployez tous et tous beaucoup sur
le terrain il y avait quelque chose d'un
peu curieux d'avoir du matériel
disponible sur le papier et absolument
pas disponible en termes d'effets
militaires ou en grande fragilité pour
ce faire et donc ça ça va irriguer
évidemment le tableau capacitaire tel
qu'il vous est proposé c'est en fond non
seulement et pour le coup monsieur le
sénateur P1 je ne me trompe pas en vous
disant que la comparaison entre les deux
tableaux d'une part effectivement il y a
des ambitions d'autres parc l'ambition
maintenant les pour 2035 or pour la loi
actuelle évidemment l'ambition était
pour 2025 donc là évidemment les deux
mots ne se superposent pas et surtout et
ça je on en fera la démonstration par
écrit je préfère que l'on parle de
matériel livré que de commande si on
raisonne en commande lancer tout d'un
coup on rattrape plein de choses sur 31
32 vous avez plein de chiffres
évidemment qui augmentent moi je préfère
qu'on raisonne en parc parce que c'est
ce qui correspond à un effet militaire
évidemment réel sur la cohérence
par exemple sur les blindés sur scorpion
on est quand même sur une loi de
programmation militaire qui a permis
actuellement de faire pratiquement 800
livraisons de matériel essentiellement
griffons un peu Jaguar désormais les
choses vont arriver notamment d'ici à la
fin de l'année bon dans la programmation
qu'on vous propose on parle quand même
de
2300 blindés nouveaux
pas non plus présenter les choses comme
étant complètement anecdotique avec la
scorpionisation de la plupart de nos
régiments et la particularité c'est que
face à ces 2300 on a et la formation et
le MCO et les infrastructures puisque
tout celles et ceux qui ont évidemment
visité les différents régiments ont pu
voir que scorpion nécessite des travaux
d'un froid qui sont assez
impressionnants parce que tout
simplement le griffon bah correspond à
tout un tas de logique que le nos vieux
VAB comme d'ailleurs la mx-0 versus le
jaguar correspond aussi à des
infrastructures des travaux d'infras qui
sont particuliers donc cette cohérence
là évidemment elle est importante on ne
réduit pas l'acide pour autant sinon ça
voudrait dire qu'on l'a raboterait qu'on
dire bah non on va s'arrêter avant c'est
pas le cas de fait sur scorpion on a une
cible qui va aller jusqu'en 2031 2032
qui dépasse donc la LPM alors après on
peut se poser la question est-ce que
c'est grave
parce que je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure en introduction on peut avoir
une conception scolaire des choses et
avec la terre est plate et avoir des
lois de programme coup près qui s'arrête
programme fini puis on démarre un
programme nouveau à partir de 31 moi je
considère que étaler quelque peu ce
n'est pas grave c'est pas grave déjà si
ça correspond bien à la capacité des
forces d'interagir et de et d'exécuter
les missions qu'on leur a confié
je vous cache pas que politiquement ce
serait plus facile pour moi de vous dire
vous avez vu on reprend tous les
chiffres de la dernière fois on les
remet dans la colonne et puis pour
essayer de faire entrer le rayé dans la
tête d'oreiller on diminue le MCO on
diminue l'entraînement et l'activité des
forces bon je pense que ce choix serait
irresponsable et documenterai en
chiffres évidemment pour répondre à vos
questions mais je pense que cette
cohérence là
de fait la scorpionisation devient
irréversible
et c'est aussi ce qui est attendu enfin
je veux dire 2018 lorsque vous avez voté
le votre programmation militaire
programme scorpion après tout qu'est-ce
que ça voulait vraiment dire est-ce que
ça allait être concret est-ce que ça va
vraiment arriver non seulement ça arrive
vraiment et vous vous apprêtez à
examiner le PM qui va la rendre
fondamentalement irréversible oui le
restaurant encore pour 2031 32
on peut faire en sorte si vous le
souhaitez dans l'enveloppe des 413
milliards on peut faire en sorte de
finir ce scorpion en 2030
mais faudra forcément réduire autre
chose soit le MCO soit l'entraînement ou
alors on va piocher dans les patchs qui
me semble clé le soleil le spatial le
renseignement et c'est là quand même on
rentre et le présent comment on a
toujours dit de faire carte sur table
donc je le fais
en cela la LPN sans boîte à la
précédente mais comment ceci à pivoter
pour reprendre l'expression que vous
avez relevé dans la ministre oui il est
clair que ce n'est pas le nombre de
griffons qui feront complètement la
sécurité de la nation française ça je en
fonction je vois bien les missions qu'on
confie à nos armées de décaler enfin pas
décaler mais de lisser sur deux ans de
plus la réalisation de la cible griffon
non mais je pourrais revenir mais c'est
surtout 31 32 après vous avez raison
monsieur Center puisque vous avez
forcément une colonne 30 une colonne 35
après il y a du détail entre 30 et 35 et
si vous le souhaitez évidemment on peut
donner mais j'ai envie de vous dire et
même si c'était 35 si on raisonne en
effet militaire pour les missions que
l'on confie à l'armée française est-ce
que finir plus tard la scorpionisation
est-ce que c'est si grave pour la
sécurité du pays je pose la question ce
que je sais
mais par définition le mouvement est
enclenché ce que je sais en revanche ou
alors c'est comme si les sénateurs de
lait je n'avais rien dit sur la
souveraineté au moins vous êtes cohérent
monsieur le Seigneur vous avez tout de
suite tweeté après le discours du
président de la République au mois de
janvier que 413 milliards d'euros
n'était pas suffisant vous avez le
mérite de cette cohérence mais si on
considère que l'effort est quand même
déjà important je dis que oui forcément
il a dû faire il fallait faire des choix
et je pense aujourd'hui dangereux de
négliger le spatial le cyber par exemple
le renseignement ou la défense solaire
parce que la dissuasion ne couvre pas
tout parce que monastère
et donc par définition il y a des choses
qu'on enclenche et des choses sur
lesquelles on prendra un peu plus de
temps pour les terminer ça c'est un
premier cas pratique que nous assumons
il y a un deuxième cas pratique qui est
différent il tient davantage de la vie
de l'industriel je prends l'exemple
parce que la ministre est revenue sur
les segments maritime je prends
l'exemple des FDI par exemple
dans la
projet de loi la copie qui vous est
proposée présentée vous avez par exemple
deux décalages de FDI sur la période bon
pour une raison simple c'est que tout
simplement nous souhaitons étirer et
tendre l'activité sur les chaînes de
production de l'Orient le plus longtemps
possible en essayant de faire le pari
d'un succès de contrat à l'export dont
je tairai le nom du pays puisque la
séance est transmise
qui nous permettrait justement de
d'intercaler deux frégates pour
l'exportation et sortir les FDI
française un peu plus tard ce qui nous
permettrait de garantir un niveau de
production pour les équipes de Lorient
qui serait plus plus long sur la période
c'est un deuxième cas pratique de de
décalage de lissage mais qui obéit aussi
pour le coup sur les gros objets à des
opportunités à l'exportation troisième
sujet dans le tableau et là je vous prie
de mon excusé mais j'assume ce que font
les équipes du ministère il y a quelques
coquilles notamment la coquille sur les
drones que vous avez un manquement
relevé puisque c'est votre grande
passion non pas de relever les coquilles
mais les drones monsieur le sénateur
Perrin et donc je vous que la cible est
bien la même que la LPM précédente je
crois que le rapporteur à l'Assemblée
nationale l'a vu aussi comme vous et
fera un amendement pour la corriger la
nouveauté en revanche c'est que sur les
patrolleurs on va surtout durcir les
charges en portée d'armement et de
renseignements donc là pour le coup ça
peut être utile que les deux chambres ou
les deux commissions s'articulent pour
la rédaction nouvelle du rapport annexé
je sais que on me posera la question
tout à l'heure mais je crois quand même
aussi que parce que j'ai eu la question
à l'Assemblée nationale
nos industriels désormais ont beaucoup
de visibilité et quand j'entends dire
que c'est décalages viennent les
fragiliser je dois avouer que j'ai du
mal à le comprendre j'ai du mal à le
comprendre pour deux raisons un déjà
comme on n'a pas pris un couteau pour
réduire la cible on l'a étalé ce qui est
quand même dans le monde de l'industrie
permet quand même d'étaler plus
longtemps les capacités de production
ça dépend ça dépend des segments 2 on
est quand même tous croyants dans nos
capacités à l'export
quand on voit les efforts que les
Ukrainiens font pour dire du bien du
César c'est quand même bien le drame
c'est une externe n'en vend pas un peu
plus à l'export un jour quand même bon
je dis les choses un peu clairement mais
je pense que faudra aussi qu'on
s'accorde entre nous mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs sur le rapport entre nos
industriels et la seule commande
publique comment le public est là pour
garantir et là pour se créer et là pour
protéger je crois qu'on est parce que
aussi c'est notre modèle de souveraineté
français évidemment qui va avec mais
enfin au bout d'un moment c'est aussi
l'exportation qui nous permet quand même
d'équilibrer un peu l'affaire et puis
troisième chose je vous rassure 413
milliards me dites-vous mais comment se
fait-il que
ça n'est pas plus d'effet pour nos
industriels vous avez pas dit ça comme
ça mais en clair vous relayez
l'inquiétude des industriels sur les les
différents lissages si je prends les
exemples d'Arcus et nexters
et peut-être tant mieux puisque il est
très soucieux et deniers publics il vaut
mieux qu'il n'entendent pas ces chiffres
arcus va connaître une augmentation j'en
suis même certain
Bruno Le Maire et Gabriel Attal aussi
le arcus arcus dans la période qui va
venir mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
va voir son chiffre d'affaires pour la
partie commande publique militaire
française augmentée de 40 %
Nexter
nextère
90% de chiffre d'affaires en plus pour
cette loi de programmation militaire
donc je m'en réjouis et on s'en réjouit
tous ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que je tiendrai peut-être d'autres
chiffres à disposition sur les autres
entreprises et je suis pas en train de
dire que c'est bien ou pas bien je pense
que c'est très bien et que ça va nous
permettre de reprendre aussi en muscle
pour nos différentes industries mais de
décaler d'un deux trois années certains
programmes ne créent pas un risque ou
alors faudra me le démontrer parce que
ce n'est pas vrai et de toute façon vous
connaissez bien notre système s'il y
avait un risque on le saurait déjà on
aurait déjà les syndicats des
différentes entreprises qui m'aurait
saisi et donc je tiens à être rassurant
sur cette affaire là
l'engagement ici devant nous aujourd'hui
qui aura pas de fermeture de site nulle
part dans aucune industrie de la défense
liée à la loi de programmation militaire
aux Etats
une chose je les situations de chaque
entreprise sont très différentes et
comme je ne suis pas ministre de la
France insoumise je prendrai pas
d'engagement des Magog comme ça au pied
levé en tout cas il faut se dire les
choses
oui
vous avez raison monsieur le sénateur
fait mal mais vous n'êtes pas de la
France insoumise non plus bon
pardonnez-moi monsieur le Président
c'est de ma faute non ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que il y a quelque
chose Monsieur Center Perrin qui me
paraît factuel c'est que la dépense
publique militaire elle augmente sous
cette période c'est concret et ce n'est
pas que non mais et quand c'est pas pour
de l'achat on revient à ce que c'est
pour du MCO donc dans tous les cas non
mais c'est important je pense que c'est
dit aussi quelque chose la répartition
de la valeur et ça pour le coup moi je
suis vraiment la disposition du Sénat
pour qu'on puisse regarder aussi
entreprise par entreprise que ça veut
dire parce que je pense qu'on a besoin
de mettre de la transparence aussi cette
affaire après il y a pas d'esprit
polémique je le dis vraiment comme ça
madame l'administre vous m'avez
également posé une question sur le mgcs
et la 400m
socle à 35 ça veut dire que pour nos
besoins militaires l'Armée de l'Air et
de l'Espace estimant nous parlons
qu'avec 35 appareils nous sommes
capables de remplir la plupart des
missions quand je dis socle ça veut dire
que dans les revoyures que je vous ai
proposé il faut évidemment se poser la
question si on augmente pas ou
enfin oui ou non en tout cas avoir
deuxième des choses moi je souhaite et
je le dis publiquement je souhaite que
Airbus regarde très près des
perspectives à l'export
je le dis puisque quand on regarde ce
qui s'est passé à Kaboul malheureusement
l'évacuation de l'Afghanistan quand on
regarde ce qui s'est passé à cartoon on
voit bien que l'aviation de transport
technique et donc le A400M est un
vecteur absolument formidable pour ce
genre d'opération que ça permet en plus
effectivement de lutter contre quelques
tyrannies de l'éloignement et compris
pour nos outre-mer d'ailleurs dans la
cible à 35 certains vont être dédiés au
seul territoire d'outre-mer genre
l'occasion de de le décliner les
Espagnols ont revu également un peu leur
cible à la baisse pour eux nous on garde
un socle un minimum 35 avec la cible à
50 bon mais je souhaite effectivement
pour les lignes de production que l'on
puisse lever quelques options en
exportation quand je dis ça c'est que
j'ai déjà des intuitions ou des idées et
je souhaite qu'on puisse les concrétiser
je peux pas en dire plus ici dans une
audition là aussi retransmise mais c'est
absolument clé mgcs les discussions ont
reprises récemment avec l'Allemagne
quand je dis qu'elles ont reprises c'est
que essentiellement c'est le SCAF qui
nous avait évidemment beaucoup occupé
ces derniers temps le Scaff la France
est chef de fil le mgcs les Allemands
sont chefs de fil je le rappelle pour la
méthodologie actuellement au moment où
je vous parle les armées de terre les
deux pays sont en train de se parler
pour s'accorder sur les attendus du
projet cavalerie blindé horizon 2040
équipé enfin occupé
telle opérable à distance première
question rapport pour le coup au drone
autour du char là aussi c'est une vraie
question qui convient de se poser
interconnexion connectivité là on a des
choses à apporter évidemment avec le
savoir-faire dédié de scorpion une
ministérielle va être prévue avec le
ministre de la défense allemande Boris
Pistorius avant le 14 juillet dont
l'objet pratiquement unique sera le mgcs
pour bien commencer à définir le rôle de
chacun entreprise allemande entreprise
française mais surtout pour ne pas
reproduire les débuts du SCAF avant de
se poser les questions de qui fait quoi
chez les industriels proposer déjà les
questions de qui veut quoi dans les deux
armées de terre sur le produit final
troisième chose pourquoi ça avance de
nouveau bien et vite tout simplement
parce que l'Allemagne cédant un certain
nombre de léopards et un syndrome de
pays cédants évidemment les Léopards
comment ça monter dans ces différents
pays la question mais et c'est quoi la
suite du léopard et donc évidemment les
parlements aussi ont mis la pression sur
un certain nombre de de ces pays de la
de la coalition d'Hitler et ce qui
permet aussi de se projeter sur la suite
ce qui est recréer un peu de un peu de
mouvement donc ça c'est un échange qu'on
a eu communiste allemand en marge du
sommet de Madrid sur le Scaff et donc la
date de la ministériel va bientôt être
fixée donc les choses avancent de
nouveau je pense que d'ici d'ailleurs la
discussion fin juin fin juin au Sénat de
la LPM on sera en mesure d'y revenir
devant vous avec des éléments un peu
plus précis
alors
pour être agréable au sénateur guerriot
qui a des contingences de transport je
vais passer directement 212 en demandant
à Michel gréaume de nous pardonner cette
ce petit switch allons 212 le au titre
du soutien de la politique de défense et
Joël s'exprime au nom de marie-arlett
Carlotti qu'aura porteur il faudra donc
les questions des deux rapporteurs
allons-y merci monsieur le Président je
vais essayer de tracer rapide
et j'aurais monsieur le ministre faire
un focus sur les ressources extra
budgétaires que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure et plus spécifiquement au sujet
de la politique immobilière du ministère
qui représente un des postes de recettes
expressément
identifiés pour financer ses ressources
supplémentaires le parc immobilier du
ministère de la Défense est déjà sous
tension à l'heure actuelle
l'insuffisance de l'offre et
d'hébergement à justifier un programme
d'investissement spécifique pour
construire ou réhabiliter 30000 places
d'hébergement pendant la programmation
actuelle Man en vigueur donc
2019-2025 et donc ma question est dans
ce contexte tendu pourriez-vous nous
indiquer clairement quelles sont les
sessions immobilières qui sont
envisagées par le ministère pour générer
les 474 millions d'euros de recettes
prévues et quelles mesures seront prises
en compte pour que ces sessions ne
dégradent pas l'offre du ministère en
matière d'hébergement des militaires
ensuite permettez-moi de lire
l'intervention de Madame Marie Arlette
Carlotti qui est donc avec moi
rapporteur du programme 212
le projet de loi de programmation
militaire que nous examinerons ce
printemps à pour ambition de transformer
les armées il est élaboré dans un
contexte de dégradation préoccupant de
notre environnement stratégique et de
réaffirmation de notre volonté d'être en
mesure de faire face à un engagement
majeur or en dépit de la poursuite de la
hausse du budget des armées inscrits
dans le projet de loi la trajectoire en
effectif qu'il contient et pour le moins
paradoxal malgré notre volonté affichée
d'accélérer notre préparation à la haute
intensité le projet de loi prévoit de
diviser par deux les créations nettes
d'effectives dans les armées pour 2024
et 2025 par rapport à la programmation
actuelle dans le même temps certains
choix stratégiques structurant pour le
format de nos armées reste incertain et
cette égard monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelle
hypothèse vous avez faite pour la
poursuite de l'opération sentinelle pour
construire ce projet de LPM et plus
largement pourriez-vous nous indiquer
clairement quels sont vos hypothèses de
travail en matière de contribution
effectifs du ministère pour assurer des
missions de sécurité civile dans le
cadre des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 merci Joëlle
réponse de Monsieur le Ministre merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Sénateur gueriou alors sur d'abord le
volet 13 milliards dans la partie
purement recette donc pour le coup le
président ministre Moscovici avait
estimé que les 5,9 milliards de recettes
elle était bien documentée donc c'était
plutôt sur les marges frictionnelles et
les reports de charge pour le coup qu'il
exactement donc sur les sur les sur les
recettes pour le coup les choses les
choses étaient claires vous avez raison
sur les sessions il convient d'être
prudent c'est pour ça que les
instructions que j'ai données sont
d'intégrer dans la copie uniquement les
sessions qui ont déjà été réalisées
c'est à dire en fait vous avez déjà des
actes des promesses de vente ou des
actes de vente qui sont en cours souvent
sur des opérations qui sont petites et
je vous rassure qui ne concerne enfin
qui jamais le parc de logement on est
sur des opérations qui désormais sont un
peu éparpillées sur l'ensemble du
territoire il y a plus les gros
mouvements fonciers postes décisions
carte militaire année 90 ou poste 2008
dans lequel vous avez des gros bouger
vous avez encore des grosses opérations
en cours mais elles ne sont pas
concernées par les recettes extra
budgétaires il y a le cas particulier du
Val de Grâce par exemple mais qui ne
rentre pas évidemment dans dans
l'affaire sur comment dire les sessions
immobilières on est sur une somme de 474
millions d'euros et si vous le souhaitez
en tant que rapporteur on peut
évidemment vous donner à quoi ça
correspond exactement enfin tout ça est
très et très documenté boulevard
Saint-Germain je crois que c'est dedans
exactement donc vraiment on est en fait
c'est la queue de comète c'est la queue
de commettre des décisions qui ont été
prises depuis 10 ans et sur lequel le
temps que les actes notariés les
sociétés donc ça pour le coup on peut
évidemment vous le vous le vous le
documentez dans le détail mais
d'ailleurs parce que le sénateur Perrin
et la ministre m'ont posé beaucoup de
questions on reprendra peut-être les
interventions orales et on fera
peut-être des réponses par écrit qu'on
peut communiquer
ça j'en suis absolument convaincu mais
on peut déjà prendre de l'avance mais là
c'était en vos questions étaient en mode
revolver donc je vais essayer de
d'apporter des réponses non mais je
parle de rythme
sur le format des armées pour la
ministre Carlotti alors j'ai pas compris
l'affaire de la division par deux parce
que c'est pas le cas en fait on a la
cible de 175 000 ETP
non réalisé parce que 6000 postes
fidélisation confère ce que je disais en
introduction en fait on a repris la même
cible
à nous de les réaliser donc par
définition à la fin de cette LPM si on
est bon on assimile le TP de plus dans
le ministère que la période précédente
deux je rajouterais c'est même pas vrai
c'est plus parce que je considère que
les forces de réserve sont dans le
format je pense que notre victoire
d'ailleurs ce sera le jour on dira il y
a 300000 militaires dans ce pays dont
100000 les réservistes quand on aura
vraiment quand on intégrera la réserve
de cette manière là c'est à dire à
quelque chose et on va vers un
doublement des réserves donc par
définition on a quelque chose évidemment
là qui va en augmentation qui n'est pas
sans lien avec les différentes missions
des armées suppléance etc troisième des
choses je rappelle que la la faute avait
déjà augmenté pour l'armée de terre de
manière importante parce que sentinelle
suite aux attentats de 2015 etc et ici
on qui avait été prise par Jean-Yves Le
Drian notamment donc évidemment les
comment dire la cible est toujours là
sentinelle effectivement il y aura un le
président comment déjà parlé
régulièrement je je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord pour dire que jusqu'au Jeux
Olympiques on a besoin de la mission
plus que jamais mais au lendemain des
Jeux Olympiques faudra évidemment se
poser la question du devenir du format
de la mission sentinelle en tant que tel
tout simplement parce qu'entre temps le
ministre de l'Intérieur vous a proposé
des augmentations d'effectifs importants
pour le ministère de l'Intérieur enfin
le bobo a continué sa transformation
donc après faut sûrement imaginer des
choses qui sont peut-être un peu
différentes il faut pas sortir
complètement l'armée française des
missions intérieures de lutte contre le
terrorisme parce qu'on sait jamais je
pense qu'il faut garder de l'agilité et
de l'entretien mais je pense qu'il faut
il faudra évidemment se reposer sur la
sur la doctrine
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors nous
revenons au 178 la préparation est
l'emploi des forces Michel gréaume qui
s'exprime aussi au nom de Olivier
sigoletti merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je poserai
également donc la question de mon corps
rapporteur Olivier sigolotti empêché ce
jour la guerre en Ukraine a changé la
donne remettant au cœur des priorités
les services de soutien les stocks de
munitions et la préparation
opérationnelle elle a imposé une forme
de vérité des prix sur ce que coûte la
guerre on ne pourra désormais plus
rogner comme cela a été fait y compris
lors de la précédente LPM et nous
l'avions souligné lors de
l'actualisation sur l'entraînement le
MCO les stocks et les services de
soutien dans ces conditions malgré les
efforts annoncés nous sommes soucieux de
l'incision des informations qui nous
sont présentées les chiffres de
progression de l'entretien programmé du
matériel sont globaux sans aucune
sécurité en effet une augmentation de 14
milliards d'euros sur les 7 ans est
annoncé avec quel rythme de réalisation
quel objectif quelle priorité le
Parlement ne devrait-il pas en être
informé et en débattre nous sommes
également étonnés du référentiel retenu
pour présenter de façon avantagèse des
objectifs affichés les chiffres de la
remontée de la préparation
opérationnelle sont comparées à la cible
du document budgétaire pour 2023 si on
les compare à la cible de la précédente
LPM forcée de constater qu'il n'y a pas
de progression les objectifs sont à
changer car non atteints vous me direz
qu'il ne devait être atteint à l'issue
de la LPM soit à 2025 mais là encore
nous n'avons aucun tableau d'objectifs
intermédiaires il y a donc fort à
craindre si nous ne remetions pas à
cette situation que la même situation se
reproduise au cours de cette LPM la
remontée de la préparation
opérationnelle sera rognée lors de
chaque actualisation dites à deux PM
comme cela a été le cas précédemment
pourquoi n'a-t-on plus d'objectifs
d'entraînement sur les chars légers
mx10rc et les vagues
Ultima qui seront pourtant maintenus en
activité les services de soutien doivent
bénéficier de 4 milliards
supplémentaires en ces temps par rapport
à la précédente LPM qui ne répondait pas
à tous les besoins comment pouvons-nous
juger si c'est suffisant sans autre
précision que des exemples de
réalisation à l'horizon de 2030 quel
sera les para répartition entre les
services de soutien comment expliquer
que les services auditionnés ne puissent
pas nous indiquer qu'elles sont leurs
besoins pour cette période ces montants
comprennent-ils les crédits du titre 2
c'est à dire l'augmentation des
effectifs sur l'augmentation des stocks
de munitions 16 milliards
supplémentaires soient annoncés mais les
besoins prévisibles en infrastructures
de stockage et l'adaptation du simu ne
sont pas mentionnées faut-il comprendre
que cela pas prévu que nous avions des
espaces de stock de stockage vide et
ainsi mieux surdimensionné tel n'est pas
l'impression qu'il se dégage lorsqu'on
sait les attritions qu'on subit les
services de soutien au cours des
précédentes LPM je conclus brièvement
sur les contrats opérationnels comment
expliquer que les moyens détaillés dans
les postures de réactivité comme dans le
complément en code engagement majeur
soit réduit par rapport aux contrat
opérationnel prévu par la précédente LPM
on s'attendait plutôt à ce que la
perspective d'un engagement majeur
conduise à des augmenter ou au moins
aller stabiliser surtout ces sujets mon
cours apporterait moi-même attendons vos
précisions merci beaucoup le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur président madame
la signatrice alors bon déjà une
question de forme
comment juger sur la base du projet de
loi si c'est suffisant c'est pour ça que
évidemment il y a les auditions et que
bien évidemment on accepte toutes les
questions-réponses je dis juste qu'il y
a beaucoup de choses qui ne peuvent pas
figurer dans le projet de loi je pense
qu'on le comprend bien la première loi
de programmation militaire portée par
Pierre Messmer et Michel Debré en 1960
faisait quatre articles
je dis pas que c'est bien pas bien je
constate quand même que c'est déjà plus
dense aujourd'hui
donc il y a ce qui relève de la loi il y
a ce qui relève de ce que le
gouvernement peut donner au
parlementaire qui n'a peut-être pas la
force de la loi mais enfin que quand
même une sacrée force parce que il en va
quand même de la sincérité de cette
affaire globale donc je vous rassure
toutes les questions trouveront des
réponses les services du ministère sont
là pour ça et on prendra le temps qu'il
faut c'est pour ça que dans le présent
Cambon a voulu deux auditions celle-ci
post Conseil des ministres plus très
important une audition en sortant de
l'Assemblée nationale parce que le texte
par définition aura certainement bougé
un peu et donc on prendra le temps qu'il
faut et moi à côté si le faux évidemment
je suis à la disposition de chacun ça
c'est pour la méthode mais je pense que
une loi de programmation militaire d'un
grand pays ne peut pas évidemment mettre
plein de détails techniques dedans ou
alors on contredise que la ministre que
Noé Mouret disait tout à l'heure c'est
on perd en vision stratégique on perd en
intention politique et je pense que
c'est plutôt ça sur lequel évidemment il
faut il faut revenir
sur l'entretien programmé du matériel on
pourra vous en donner le détail on
partait 35 milliards d'euros sur la LPM
en cours pour la porter à 49 milliards
d'euros sur la période à venir donc
évidemment on peut le regarder par armée
ou par typologie de matériel cela va
sans dire et ça pour le coup c'était
fort là vous voyez 35 49 ça répond à mon
sujet cohérent et masse atypiquement
passer de 35 milliards d'euros à 49
milliards d'euros bah voilà vous avez
les équilibres commencent à se dessiner
entre évidemment les efforts d'achat et
les efforts d'entretien de ce matériel
deuxième des choses sur l'activité je
pense que vous avez raison ça prend du
temps de faire remonter l'activité on
était sur 46 milliards d'euros sur la
loi de programmation actuelle et on va
vers 65 milliards d'euros par la période
à venir sur une augmentation absolument
prodigieuse pour le coup elle aussi on
en parle moins que le capacité à le
tableau comme d'habitude mais pour le
coup vous la raison de la pointe du
doigt parce que c'est là où il faut
impérativement qu'on se donne les
objectifs de précisément remplir les
objectifs en 2030 après ça prend du
temps c'est pas qu'une affaire d'argent
puisque derrière il y a évidemment une
réalité un peu humaine logistique et
organisationnel mais il est clair que le
pari de la cohérence c'est celui-là
alors après puisque
par l'amendement et par la modification
de la LPM on peut très bien réduire ces
items pour satisfaire à la question
posée tout à l'heure je n'ai pas dit que
le sénateur Perrin voulait ça mais on
peut réorienter la masse et évidemment
compresser l'entretien programmé du
matériel ou l'activité et là vous avez
évidemment un choix et donc j'essaierai
aussi de vous faire cette démonstration
que là pour le coup je le fais d'autant
plus que ce sont nos militaire qui l'ont
construit donc ça ne revient pas c'est
une c'est une instruction politique mise
en oeuvre et militaire par le Sénat mis
en oeuvre par les équipes de Balard mais
je pense que l'équilibre pour le coup là
et le bon
va bene XRC vous avez raison il y a on
est tenté de parler beaucoup du matériel
nouveau il faut faire attention matériel
qui va continuer de demeurer dans les
armées et qui font partie du format
d'armée donc s'il y a des données
évidemment à transmettre sur le sujet on
le fera bien volontiers et quatrième
chose le T2 est toujours sorti de ces
chiffres pour le coup on sort toujours
les 98 milliards d'euros prévu pour la
période à venir contre 88 d'ailleurs
dans la période en cours précédente on
sort toujours le T2 des chiffres tels
qui sont présentés
merci alors nous allons passer au 144
environnements et prospectif de la
politique de défense avec les
interventions de Pascal Alizard et de
Yannick vogrenard allons-y merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre ce projet de loi de
programmation militaire
et peu dessert sur la question de
l'innovation le rapport annexé indique
que la future programmation permettra je
cite d'anticiper certains besoins
capacités par des innovations de rupture
et d'assumer des paris technologiques
pour anticiper la génération future
dès lors que le contexte et les menaces
le permet sur le ministre on ne peut
qu'être d'accord
mais néanmoins pourriez-vous nous
préciser quelles sont les priorités en
matière d'études amont c'est ma première
question la seconde qui est d'ailleurs
très complémentaire vous nous l'aviez
indiqué lors de votre précédente
audition ce projet de LPM prévoit un
effort de 10 milliards d'euros sur sept
ans au titre de l'innovation dont 7,5
milliards pour les études amont
pourriez-vous vous présenter une
ventilation
prévisions d'utilisation de ces crédits
pour chaque année de la programmation et
dernier point ça déjà été évoqué mais la
question de l'inflation est quand même
une question
préoccupante et je dirais au-delà
effectivement des jeux d'indice et des
approches ce sont des exercices que je
connais un petit peu de par ma formation
et mon ancienne mon ancienne profession
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit peu plus en termes d'estimation
d'anticipation
quelles ont été les modes de calcul y
a-t-il différents jeux d'hypothèses
puisque la question qui est derrière qui
vient aussitôt c'est quels sont ou
existe-t-il des plans correctifs en lien
notamment avec les industriels puisque
les chiffres dont on parle concernant
l'inflation sont quand même très très
variables et ça peut pratiquement faire
entre une demi-année voire une année de
cette LPM donc c'est assez colossal en
termes d'impact ça veut dire aussi que
c'est assez colossal en termes d'impact
d'équipement pour nos armées mais c'est
aussi un impact important pour les
industriels en termes de plancha donc
voilà pouvez nous vous nous donner
quelques quelques infos supplémentaires
même si déjà je l'ai bien entendu vous
nous avez donné quelques informations
merci Yannick
[Musique]
merci Président Monsieur ministre dans
votre intervention vous avez parlé de
mer calme et de mer agitée dans le
domaine du renseignement nous sommes
véritablement en mer agitée
voir en forte tempête et pas seulement
s'agissant de l'Ukraine mais également
au moment de où nos soldats et
intervenaient en Afrique et
particulièrement en Mali au Mali donc le
rôle du service du renseignement
extérieur est extrêmement important et
donc vous êtes un an cet après-midi nous
nous souhaitons en vous écoutant nous
souhaitons avoir des précisions en
entrant peut-être un peu plus dans le
détail par rapport aux auditions que
Pascal à lézard et moi-même avons fait
les services que nous avons entendus ont
tous fait tard d'arbitrage encore en
cours c'est le cas en ce qui concerne
les crédits de fonctionnement et
d'investissement du renseignement à nos
questions sur la répartition de
l'augmentation de 60% des crédits de
renseignements sur la période
2024-2030 pour atteindre un total de 5
milliards d'euros aucun des trois
services concernés donc vous avez donc
la responsabilité la DGSE la Direction
du renseignement militaire la réduction
du renseignement de la sécurité de la
défense n'a répondu sur les progressions
respectives
considérant qu'il y avait encore des
arbitrages qui étaient en cours en
revanche deuxième aspect ils ont
clairement indiqué que ces augmentations
de crédit ne concerne pas très
précisément et même du tout le personnel
celle-ci se situe donc or enveloppe des
5 milliards d'euros pour le
renseignement
certes les investissements techniques
sont indispensables pour éviter le
décrochage par rapport au meilleur
service de renseignement étranger mais à
côté de cela la DGSE compte actuellement
près de 6000 agents ce service reste
encore relativement modeste en effectif
par rapport notamment nos voisins
britanniques qui en sont plus de 11000
mais aussi allemand
quels sont donc précisément les
objectifs de renforcement des personnels
du renseignement en effet les services
nous répondent qui n'ont pas encore de
connaissances sur l'évolution de leur de
leur personnel et la direction des
ressources humaines nous indique que la
cible 2030 d'augmentation de 6000 dans
300 emplois restent à répartir entre
grand domaine d'emploi à la fois unité
opérationnelle le cyber et le
renseignement donc quels sont vos
arbitrages budgétaires et de recrutement
merci de pouvoir nous permettre de voir
un peu plus clair
monsieur le ministre oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président pour le volet
innovation de fait je pense qu'on peut
on peut sûrement compléter le rapport
annexé ou pendant les débats venir en
dire davantage parce que pour le coup je
pense que c'est un des éléments de
transformation intéressant je trouve de
la LPM on peut pas ne pas voir avec des
sous technologiques en cours vont être
brutaux ce qui permet peut-être d'en
citer quelques-uns en termes
d'illustration 10 milliards d'euros
global mais c'est compliqué d'ailleurs
de les quantifier des milliards c'est
l'appareil PM pur
mais il y a aussi tout ce que la BTD
évidemment et nos PME accomplissent en
propre donc évidemment il faut le
détourer non si on se donne des exemples
très précis armes énergie dirigée
premier exemple sur lequel il nous faut
avancer on met une mise au départ de 100
millions d'euros justement pour
travailler sur cette affaire l'hyper
vélocité cela va sans dire pour 300
millions d'euros la guerre électronique
des choses existent déjà enfin c'est un
travail qu'il faut recommencer en
permanence pour 250 millions d'euros
l'intelligence artificielle
et ça pour le coup je pense que quand on
voit les applications civiles ça dit
quelque chose de la puissance de ce que
ça peut donner sur le terrain militaire
sont d'ailleurs
poser des questions d'éthique aussi au
milieu de tout cela vous savez
évidemment c'est aussi un des points
absolument clair le quantique qui est un
point clé compris pour les cryptes enfin
le cryptage de données de demain etc
donc ça ce sont des exemples qui sont
qui sont très très précis on peut y
rajouter évidemment les sujets liés
spatial et au drone là aussi plutôt que
de rattraper un retard qu'on a pris
autant faire un saut technique d'une
génération de matériel ça veut donc dire
évidemment qu'il faut il faut lancer les
opérations d'innovation le plus vite
possible sur des études amont pour
répondre à votre question on était sur
la LPM actuelle à 6,8 milliards d'euros
pour la période 24 30 à 7,5 milliards
d'euros donc là aussi on a quand même un
effort qui est fait sur les seules
études et pour le bloc innovation donner
quelques détails enfin ça donne un tout
petit peu ce que nous attendons et qui
va venir aussi permettre à la idée
l'agence de l'innovation de défense qui
a été créé sous l'empire de cette LPM en
cours évidemment de de produire et de
donner ses effets sur le sur le pardon
sur l'inflation bon j'ai déjà quand même
pas mal pas mal répondu est-ce qu'il y a
plusieurs jeux d'hypothèses en fait il y
a quand même une ligne qui est donnée
par Bercy et les hypothèses qui sont
retenues sont les hypothèses les plus
les plus pessimistes pour faire vite
enfin pessimiste oui mais c'est Bercy
donc c'est plutôt fait pour ça et on a
évidemment choisi de faire ce pari là ce
qui veut donc dire aussi que on des
clauses de révision régulièrement et je
manquerai pas évidemment dans un formel
Parlement en fonction des effets que
cela peut produire ça ça va sans dire on
voit bien de façon d'un semestre à
l'autre voire même d'un trimestre à
l'autre les choses peuvent être assez
brutales pour les services de
renseignements j'ai notifié au 3
services monsieur le sénateur leur cible
de TP et la répartition des crédits donc
peut-être que ça s'est télescopé avec le
cycle de l'audition en tout cas moi ça
me permet peut-être pour la première
fois publiquement d'en donner la
répartition devant vous plus 60% on le
disait d'augmentation sur les deux LPM
donc c'est absolument
considérable c'est plus de 5 milliards
d'euros pour les trois services si on
rentre dans le détail pour la seule DGSE
c'est 4,6 milliards d'euros
bon sur une logique mais quelque chose
d'important l'ADM 600 millions d'euros
ça n'a l'air de rien mais c'est x 2
avec des augmentations de TP importante
des enjeux aussi de système de prime
pour la fidélisation des civils et des
militaires qui travaillent à la DRM et
pour la DSD pareil une augmentation
importante 233 millions d'euros c'est le
service le moins connu mais c'est
sûrement des services qui sera le plus
en plus sollicité sur les sujets de
contresionales d'un gérance de sécurité
au sein de notre pays TD au sein de
notre système de défense ils ont fait
beaucoup plus de contrôle prévention de
la radicalisation ces dernières années
et de nouveau ils vont revenir sur des
missions plus souveraines plus
classiques peut-être au sens
grégalien du terme en tout cas c'est une
évolution importante sur les cibles de
TP pour la seule DGSE la cible socle de
TP pourquoi je dis ça que je vous le
dire ensuite mais ce sera de plus 728 et
TP sur la période
la réalité c'est qu'on peut faire plus
parce qu'on revient à l'enveloppe
globale des ETP du ministère des armées
dans lequel en gestion on va aussi
pouvoir peut-être répartir un peu un peu
mieux les choses moi je l'ai dit au DGSE
je pense que le premier combat amené
c'est comme la fidélisation parce que si
on parle des problèmes de fidélisation
dans les armées
à la DGSE je crois que le sujet taille
on parle de cyber-combattant on a des
gens jeunes formidables qui se forment
et qui 4 ou 5 ans quitte la boîte pour
aller faire autre chose et donc il y a
la réflexion sur le nombre mais je crois
que la réflexion sur la fidélisation me
semble tout aussi importante en tout cas
sur les fonctions cyber ces clés
puisqu'on perd des cerveaux après et il
faut recommencer une génération de
formation bon après je crois que dans le
cadre de la DPR on aura l'occasion de
revenir peut-être dans un format plus
adoc aussi aux enjeux de la DGSE
peut-être dans la période à venir dans
le cadre de LPM mais dans un format plus
adapté
merci Monsieur Miss alors dernier
programme le 129 coordination du travail
gouvernemental j'excuse Olivier Cadic et
Michael Valley qui sont justement en
audition pour préparer
ce travail LPM et donc les questions
qu'il souhaitez-vous poser vont l'être
par André gatelin que je vous remercie
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez du 2 en 1 donc je
transmets les questions de mes deux
collègues et j'ai la chance et le
bonheur de participer au groupe de
travail sur la cyber-défense avec eux et
donc c'est des sujets auxquels nous
sommes très attachés notamment dans le
cadre de cette LPM et on voit que la
résilience cyber a été érigée en
objective stratégique par la revue
nationale stratégique et le président de
la République avait annoncé dans un de
ses discours sont souhaits de voir
doubler notre capacité de traitement des
attaques cyber majeures on se demande
d'ailleurs si le seul objectif de
doublement de capacité est suffisant
quand on sait la programmation
aujourd'hui exponentielle des menaces
cyber qui sont répertoriés tant par
l'annecy que par cyber malveillance
alors au-delà de ces chiffres comment
véritablement inscrire dans la prochaine
LPM la nécessité de rapprocher à la fois
les fonctions défensives et offensives
qui sont traditionnellement en France et
structurellement séparés dans notre
organisation pour que la défense de nos
intérêts soient mieux intégrées
notamment entre l'annecy pour le volet
civil et le comme cyber pour le volet
militaire la seconde question un rapport
là à la partie programmation
financière au sein de la LPM le rapport
annexé à la LPM prévoit 4 milliards
d'euros pour la cyberdéfense afin
d'augmenter les effectifs de s'adapter
bien sûr aux évolutions technologiques
d'accompagner les entreprises du secteur
de la défense et d'appuyer ainsi en case
en cas de crise cyber national alors
quel sera demande mes collègues
concrètement la cible d'augmentation des
effectifs dans ce domaine d'autre part
quel sera l'impact budgétaire de la LPM
sur l'ensis le journal Le Monde du 18
avril 2023 indiqué je cite qu'une part
non négligeable des nouveaux crédits de
la LPM devraient aussi irriguer l'ancien
or Nancy récemment nous l'avons audité
auditionnés nous a certifié qu'aucun
crédit de la LPM ne lui sont destinés
alors qu'en est-il monsieur le ministre
merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur gatelin emporte-parole de ses
collègues alors l'annecy n'est pas dans
la LPM parce que tout simplement elle
est sous la tutelle du Premier ministre
la première ministre et donc elle obéit
à un autre rythme budgétaire comme le
GDSN enfin tout ce qui est évidemment
interministériel ne rentre pas dans la
loi de programme puisque ce sont les
seuls services unités
de la défense qui sont évidemment sous
ma tutelle qui sont dans la loi
néanmoins le ministère est meneur et
vous l'avez signalé vous-même sur des
fonctions qui lui sont propres notamment
sur la lutte informatique offensive ou
défensive sur l'informatique aussi
d'influence globalement c'est 4
milliards d'euros sur la période sur
l'ensemble de ces fonctions pour le
ministère des armées c'est pratiquement
un X3 donc ça dit aussi quelque chose de
l'ambition pour le coup c'est sur
l'effort RH c'est là que vous m'avez
posé la question que que qu'il faut être
évidemment le plus le plus engagé on
sera sur une augmentation de 53 ETP pour
le seul ministère des armées réparti
entre DGSE donc on retrouve un morceau
de ce que je disais au Center le renard
à l'instant pour la boîte mais donc
répartis entre DGSE DGA puisque la DGA
évidemment un rôle majeur à jouer dans
cette affaire on connaît les fonctions
qui sont installées à bruit ailleurs et
puis évidemment les armées en tant que
tel qui disposent de quelques missions
en la matière donc là pour le coup on
est sur un des grands pivots là aussi
attendu et c'est un peu pour ça que tout
à l'heure je mettais un peu de coeur à
défendre les choix de masse et de
cohérence sur le tableau du rapport
annexé sur le nombre de griffons et
autres c'est qu'on voit bien en fait
qu'à un moment donné on rentre dans la
dans la précision des choix voilà et ça
pour le coup ça correspond à des menaces
qu'une démocratie comme la nôtre
puissance dotée peut connaître menace
cyber menace informatique menace
l'informationnelle et pour le coup il
est urgent de ne pas attendre et
d'enclencher ça là où et ce n'est fait
offense à personne de retarder la
livraison de 200 de 300 griffons bref
sur quelques années n'est pas n'a pas le
même impact sur la sécurité collective
que sur ces sujets de cyber c'est une
réalité c'est comme ça
bien alors Monsieur Miss maintenant nous
passons à ce qu'on appelle ici les
questions minutes ça peut prendre
parfois plus d'une minute bien sûr si
collègues en commençant par le président
Patriat
on va les prendre les unes des autres
vous restez dans le temps imparti car le
ministre rassurez-vous je suis très bref
je suis très bref et une petite question
d'abord merci monsieur le ministre pour
cette brillante et complète intervention
qui est montré à la fois connaissant des
dossiers mais en étant l'engagement du
gouvernement avec une LPM de 413
milliards 100 milliards de plus par
rapport à la précédente qui va faire
quand le bout du compte on aura doublé
le budget de la défense dans ce pays
c'est un effort remarquable bien sûr
merci de nous avoir donné un peu des
orientations stratégiques et notamment
ça va être faire André sur le cyber avec
60% en plus et ce qui vient d'arriver
aux États-Unis nous montre la nécessité
de le faire aujourd'hui une remarque
peut-être sur
sur le fond d'abord le retour de la
guerre sous le continent européen aurait
dû peut-être nous conduire une forme
d'une non-sacré je suis pas sûr que nous
ayons pris le meilleur chemin nous
pouvons faire mieux sur ce sur le
domaine il y a eu des critiques
incessantes sur la méthode alors que
nous avons été associés à des groupes de
travail c'est la troisième fois qu'on
échange avec vous ici au sujet de la LPM
en octobre dernier avant le budget puis
en février enfin aujourd'hui avant même
l'examen du texte donc merci d'être venu
trois fois et puis il y a aussi le
procès en insécurité de l'étude d'impact
de LPM qui s'est avéré à fonder
puisqu'elle a finalement été déclarée
conforme par le Conseil conditionnel
dans sa décision du 20 avril dernier
alors ma question était très simple vous
l'avez déjà commencé à répondre tout à
l'heure la LPM devrait assurer une
certaine visibilité pour les industriels
et leur carnet de commandes vous avez
évoqué déjà tout à l'heure certains
matériels pour répondre à d'autres
intervenants mais est-ce que le
ministère a une idée quantitative que
les commandes pour les industriels
merci beaucoup Monsieur
Jacques le nez
simplement un petit retour d'expérience
et en même temps une question
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir être
embarquée au sein d'une unité dans le
cadre de l'exercice Orion lundi mardi
très intéressant donc nous avons été
accueillis par le général qui a pas
d'eau qui nous a donné la philosophie
également donc le déroulé et l'important
c'est l'opération nous avons vu aussi
donc
l'importance de la cybersécurité non
seulement en mode défensif mais aussi en
mode offensif et c'est à peu la
nouveauté et ensuite donc d'être
intégré dans un dans un commandant
un régiment le deuxième régiment des
curatier donc on reconnaissant pour
préparer le travail des Leclerc donc
expérience intéressante bon la question
bien sûr
qui nous a Interpel c'est que cet
exercice n'a pas eu lieu depuis 30 ans
et donc avoir les meilleures armes du
monde si on veut comme le canon Sénart
c'est ce qui nous ont déménitaires mais
pouvoir les utiliser et juger de
leurification sans attente d'aller sur
les théâtres d'opérations réels c'est
aussi important surtout dans une guerre
d'intensité et
le hasard a fait que cette initiative a
été prise avant que la guerre en Ukraine
se déclare donc c'était assez
visionnaire donc la question que je pose
c'est ce que il y aura un renouvellement
de ces exercices et puis j'ai envie de
vous poser la question combien ça coûte
merci Jacques vivevette Lopez oui merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre alors je n'ai pas vous parler
de LPM ni de finance simplement vous
dire que la semaine prochaine avec une
délégation trois collègues donc Gisèle
Jourda Hugues souris et andriol nous
devons nous rendre à
Oman et aux Émirats arabes unis et donc
nous aimerions savoir quelle est la
stratégie de la France au Moyen-Orient
est-ce que vous souhaiteriez que nous
apportions un message et quel message
souhaiteriez vous que nous portions et
est-ce que vous savez si dans les
semaines ou mois à venir des visites
ministérielles sont prévues dans ces
pays merci merci Vivette Nicole durandon
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre pour rebondir sur la question
de ma collègue vivait le pèse je reviens
du Brésil donc voyage de la Commission
et je peux vous dire que les Brésiliens
vous attendent également donc ambition
au Brésil ils ont donc j'ai une question
Quels sont les marqueurs forts de ces
LPN qui nous garantissent que nos
partenaires européens et de l'OTAN donc
feront bloque avec nous en cas de
conflits de haute intensité je vous
remercie merci Nicole huxori
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre être actualisation de la loi de
programmation militaire propose une
augmentation significative du budget à
louer à nos armées pouvez-vous mettre en
perspective ce montant de 413 milliards
d'euros regarde l'effort de réarmement
de nombreux pays nous nous félicitons de
ce montant mais dans le domaine des
capacités de défense tout est relative
le budget US est de 858 milliards
d'euros en 2023 en augmentation de 8%
celui de l'Inde est en augmentation de
13% à hauteur de 75 milliards celui
programmé en 2030 par les Britanniques
et d'environ 110 milliards d'euros etc
aussi où sommes-nous dorénavant situé
quelle est notre ambition par rapport à
nos partenaires et à ceux qui ne le sont
pas et j'ai une deuxième question la
revue nationale stratégique de 2022 a
érigé en fonction stratégique
l'influence de la lutte informationnelle
la France est néanmoins très discréditée
notamment en Afrique où elle perd jour
après jour son influence mais également
à travers le globe où sa voix dans le
domaine militaire semble s'affaiblir
face aux grandes puissances pouvez-vous
préciser ce que cette LPM apportera afin
de développer nos capacités d'influence
mais également en matière de lutte
informationnelle sur le cyberespace qui
aujourd'hui est un enjeu majeur et le
sera encore davantage demain je vous
remercie merci Hugues enfin Pierre
Laurent
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre je serais très bref
en début d'audition vous avez dit qu'il
fallait tuer les rumeurs et qu'il
fallait mieux donner des chiffres et
vous avez cité
parmi les chiffres farfelus qui
circulaient ce sur la dissuasion
nucléaire donc précisément j'avais une
question là-dessus est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir justement des chiffres précis sur
ces questions parce que dans ce qu'on a
pour le moment
c'est justement une question sur lequel
il y a en vérité peu de chiffres
et donc pour ne pas
qui est des rumeurs il faudrait il
faudrait donner les chiffres donc
combien la composante de la dissuasion
nucléaire représente dont la LPM et si
vous donnez des chiffres sur ça
qu'est-ce que ça recoupe parce que dans
les choses qui sont annoncées notamment
dans le répare annexé il y a beaucoup de
choses certaines qui vont concerner la
période de la LPM mais des choses qui
vont déborder la période de la LPM vu la
bon alors vous avez tout à l'heure dit
que
l'effort allait être quand même
significativement supérieur à ce qu'il
était précédemment puisque nous sommes
nous entrons dans une période de
modernisation
généralisée de de l'arsenal nucléaire
vous avez comparé ça au saut fait dans
les années 90 mais donc est-ce que dans
les réponses écrites que vous pourriez
formuler à
l'adresse de de la commission d'ici la
discussion il pourrait y avoir des
choses plus précises que ce qu'on a pour
le moment sur
la composante budgétaire qui concerne la
dissuasion nucléaire avec du détail sur
ce que ça concerne précisément dans la
période de la LPM et peut-être au-delà
si c'est nécessaire à la compréhension
de ces chiffres parce que ça permettrait
à partir de là d'avoir un débat éclairé
sur cette question et non pas fondé sur
sur des rumeurs et je dis je fais une
dernière remarque
mais là qui s'adresse au ministre mais
peut-être plus généralement il y a des
nombreux sénateurs bien plus
expérimentés que moi dans la discussion
d'une LPM
mais il sera important de comprendre
comment va se mener le travail sur le
rapport annexé et à quel moment
parce que une fois qu'on adopte
l'article 2 on a adopté le rapport
annexé
donc à quel moment et comment se mène le
travail législatif sur le rapport annexé
sur ce point et d'expérience je rappelle
que nous avons tout à fait le droit de
demander le rapport annexé à quelques
moments que ce soit de la discussion
donc
on la demandera dans l'ordre dans
l'ordre de la discussion
monsieur le ministre pourrait répondre à
nos derniers collègues merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre patria sur l'Union bon sur
l'union sacrée on verra au moment du
vote
après je
vois deux choses puisque votre
interpellation était politique donc je
ne veux pas me dérober
une chose de fond les sujets de défense
nationale n'ont jamais été complètement
consensuel depuis les années 60 et les
questions du président Laurent le
démontrer parce que disent nucléaire ou
parce que appartenance à l'OTAN mais ça
j'ai envie de dire c'est la part noble
du débat démocratique que de pouvoir en
discuter je le disais hier au député le
coq et Roussel dans l'hémicycle sur la
diffusion nucléaire les communistes ont
toujours voté contre depuis
les années 60 et donc il y a une
cohérence du Parti communiste français
sur la question de la diffusion
nucléaire ça c'est les j'ai envie de
dire c'est les thématiques de fonds et
qui sont nobles dans le cadre du débat
politique sur la défense nationale et ça
va dans le bon sens après vous n'avez
pas tort monsieur ministre Patriat il y
a les querelles plus politiciennes et
c'est sûr que remettre en cause le
l'étude d'impact n'était pas la
meilleure manière qu'il soit de le
travail des équipes du ministère des
armées parce que c'est pas l'étude
d'impact du ministre mais l'étude impact
du ministère de nombreux États majeurs
de la Délégation Générale pour
l'Armement de des équipes du skater
général pour l'administration et de fait
c'est l'étude d'impact la plus solide
qui n'est jamais été fourni et donc
c'était un peu curieux que de voir une
alliance de circonstances de deux
présidents de groupe se fait une fois
que j'ai dit ça moi j'avance et je me
tiens la disposition évidemment et merci
de l'avoir salué moi je serai évidemment
on a prévu deux auditions du président
du Parlement étant moi-même élue
parlementaire par ailleurs je tiens à
montrer l'exemple et donc par définition
il faut que ces choses-là soient faites
avec beaucoup de sincérité dans la dans
la méthode après il y a des choix
une LPM n'est jamais une copie
complètement parfaite parce que toute
façon c'est une matière qui n'est pas
complètement scientifique gérer les
risques et la sécurité par définition
sont des sujets qui sont
particulièrement délicats et difficiles
et donc il y a une part d'aléa de risque
politique et militaire et donc aussi
parfois budgétaire qu'il nous faut
évidemment qu'il nous faut assumer votre
question était précise sur au fond la
visibilité qui est donnée monsieur
ministre sur le le chiffre d'affaires
pour les différentes entreprises j'avais
commencé tout à l'heure piqué au vif un
peu à parler d'Arcus et nexters sur la
cible scorpion peut-être vous donner des
perspectives un peu globales hors
dissuasion nucléaire pardon monsieur le
Président Laurent pour les chiffres que
j'ai sous les sous les yeux mais en tout
cas pour l'ensemble des contrats et qui
sont dit conventionnelles
Airbus peut voir son chiffre je dis peu
parce qu'après tout il y a quand même
des marchés publics des procédures à
respecter mais en tout cas on regarde la
cible de programmation qui vous est
proposée cela pourrait donner en impact
sur le chiffre d'affaires des
entreprises suivantes les augmentations
en pourcentage qui viennent Airbus
environ 40% de plus argus le disait 40 %
de plus naval group sur des sommes plus
importantes mais 15% de plus
les autres chantiers naval près de
80,90% de plus et pour cause là pour le
coup on est sur des gros objets stop and
go donc c'est assez logique enfin c'est
quand même prodigieux d'assaut 75% de
plus on était aussi sur une période dans
lequel il y a eu peu d'achats et là
évidemment on a une cible rafale quoi
qu'on en dise augmente sans oublier
évidemment tout ce qui relève des autres
des autres objets d'assaut MBDA 70% de
plus Nexter 90% de plus safran plus de
100% doublement du chiffre d'affaires
sur la période en matière de commande
publique militaire est 70% de plus alors
c'est pour ça que parfois je boue un peu
quand on me dit encore des problèmes de
visibilité pour les industriels non
enfin je veux dire
c'est pas suffisant mais c'est visible
et c'est prévisible voilà ça c'est
factuel et ça sera un impact en emploi
il faut d'ailleurs s'assurer aussi que
la politique de ces entreprises à ce si
bien aussi leurs salariés à cette
affaire enfin je pense que derrière il y
a aussi tout juste une réflexion un peu
globale à avoir en la matière monsieur
le sénateur l'aune sur Orion merci déjà
d'avoir participé parce que c'est un peu
ce que je disais tout à l'heure si on
regarde la programmation uniquement par
un tableau on va faire des erreurs il
faut la regarder par la réalité des
missions opérationnelles et la réalité
de l'entraînement on revient à la
question de la sénatrice groom tout à
l'heure sur l'activité des forces Orion
c'est ce qu'il faut faire et de fait le
dernier Orion s'il y a plus de 30 ans
c'est avant ma naissance
bon ça a été décidé par un certain
général Burkhart chef est un agent de
l'armée de terre pour la seule armée de
terre et ensuite il a décidé comme ses
mains de l'interarméiser avec
l'autorisation évidemment du président
de la République pour en faire un
exercice hors du commun non seulement
pour nous-mêmes mais aussi en interarmé
et aussi avec nos alliés bon donc ça
pour nous c'est un modèle qui permet de
stresser les choses on va faire un
retour d'expérience d'Orion moi je
souhaite qu'on puisse le partager avec
le Sénat parce que il y a des choses qui
fonctionnent bien il y a des choses qui
fonctionnent moins bien c'est le
principe de l'entraînement c'est de voir
un peu ce que ça donne et on revient à
mon débat cohérence et masse et je pense
quand on fait la visite d'Orion on voit
bien que ce qui compte c'est que tout le
monde soit bien à sa place et que tout
soit suffisamment disponible en
cohérence je crois que une visite
d'Orion permet tout de suite de le voir
les objectifs d'être en cible corps
armés en 2030 notamment pour les PC
d'état-major etc qu'on verra demain ça
dit aussi quelque chose de concret donc
ça pour le coup Orion pour moi c'est
très clair
et pour maintenir du Capesterre dans les
tableaux pour éviter évidemment d'avoir
des problèmes politiques ou industriels
il est clair que la programmation que je
vous propose une programmation
d'équilibre entre les capacités le MCO
mais aussi l'activité des forces et
Orion on est la plus belle des
démonstrations
sur la stratégie même la sénatrice le
pèse sur
Moyen-Orient alors Emir Arabes Unis vous
m'avez dit et
Oman bon Emirat Arabes Unis j'en
parlerai de manière encore peut-être
plus sachant et sa vente et pour cause
accorde défense accord de défense avec
une clause de sécurité
accorde défense avec une clause de
sécurité et des forces prépositionnées
on est sur le modèle évidemment le plus
complet on est sur une base qui est sur
un accord de défense qui est autant
tourné vers l'Indopacifique qui les
tournait vers la région golfique en tant
que tel vous aurez l'occasion de
rencontrer nos soldats là aussi de
manière interarmée avec un contrat Miral
à leur tête mais avec une composante
aérienne avec la base aérienne 104 avec
une composante terrestre et une
composante maritime bon je rappelle
quand même c'est parfois méconnu alors
que c'est public enfin lorsque les
Émirats arabes unis ont connu des
attaques de drone il y a maintenant cela
plus d'une année et demi la clause de
sécurité a
et nous avons été les premiers
réactivités à assurer les patrouilles
dans le ciel
émérien et être en réassurance du
partenaire lequel partenaire comme vous
le savez en plus achète des rafales à
côté donc on crée des conditions
d'interopérabilité et ce qui a un
message à à faire passer que nous sommes
des alliés fiables et que en disant cela
quand ils ont eu besoin de nous n'avons
pas tergiverser pendant des semaines
pour déclencher ce qu'il fallait
déclencher on l'a fait et pour le coup
on a montré beaucoup de crédibilité à
notre stratégie et golfique et
Indo-Pacifique pour le coup dans un
environnement évidemment très organisé
autour de la question de la sécurité
liée à l'Iran et donc évidemment ces
messages là vous aurez l'occasion de les
de les de les entendre de la part du
partenaire émérien et de voir à quel
point ce que nous faisons là-bas et
concret c'est pour ça que je reviens
toujours à mon rapport annexé le
matériel pour quelle mission vous verrez
les matériels qui sont utiles pour les
missions de réassurance de sécurité au
titre de la corde défense pour pour les
et ça c'est évidemment un bon exemple
bien concret VO de ministre oui j'aurai
l'occasion de d'y retourner j'y suis
déjà allé une fois avec la programmation
militaire je me déplace un peu moins
mais j'aurai l'occasion évidemment de
retourner voir nos forces et évidemment
mon homologue et le prince parce que
évidemment la relation est forte elle
nous permet aussi de nous tourner vers
l'avenir en matière industrielle il faut
il faut évidemment le souligner madame
la sénatrice Duranton alors si je vais
au Brésil je serai moins dans l'heure
donc ça pose d'autres difficultés mais
message bien reçu sur le marqueur autant
ça c'est un sujet qui mérite un
développement un peu long donc je vais
te faire de manière synthétique je crois
que la réactivité de nous avons fait
preuve sur la réassurance du floriental
de l'Europe déjà a été un marqueur fort
pas la Pologne est un très grand pays
des Américains sont nations cadres il y
avait déjà des bases ils ont fait vite
la Roumanie et l'autre grand pays nous
n'y avons pas de base nous avons fait
vite et on a su déployer des moyens
importants en intérêt
et en plus avec aussi désormais nous en
parlions avec le président Cambon avec
aussi désormais la promesse que le
partenaire roumain monte en puissance
pour sa propre armée et ça il faudra
évidemment aussi le redire à notre
partenaire et à lire roumain puisque la
notion même de nations cadre est faite
pour emmener pour grandir pour performer
et non pas pour faire à la place 2 c'est
ça aussi la solidarité au sein de
l'Alliance et donc ça passe de manière
un peu technique par les affaires de
deux points de pourcentage du PIB enfin
la réalité c'est pas que de prendre
pourcentage du pipe c'est tout
simplement avoir une armée qui monte en
compétence et qui se sert des forces
prépositionner dans le cadre de
statutation 4 pour le faire
ensuite
évidemment ce que nous faisons avec
cette loi de programmation militaire est
un marqueur
quand on augmente les budgets militaires
sur des fonctions militaires réelles
conventionnelles comme nucléaires par
définition vous participez à la
crédibilité de la posture dissuasion de
l'Alliance dans son ensemble et vous en
faites en plus un partenaire militaire
fiable la réalité c'est que l'OTAN pour
des raisons qui ont tenu la dissolution
du pack de Varsovie et devenu une
alliance qui s'était retournée beaucoup
vers des questions diplomatiques et
qu'évidemment l'agression russe en
Ukraine la remilitarisme beaucoup et
donc aussi le rôle de sacty qui est un
officier général français comme vous le
savez sur les fonctions de planification
sur évidemment l'ensemble des missions
opérationnelles que nous accomplissons
sous bannière de l'OTAN participe à la
crédibilité chaque année chaque pays
doit promettre un volume de moyens à
l'OTAN un volume de nombre d'heures de
d'aviation de chasse
de nombre d'heures ou de missions de nos
bateaux que sais-je bon il se trouve que
la France est le pays qui exécute le
mieux la promesse annuelle par rapport à
ce que nous faisons vraiment
c'est-à-dire chaque année on promet
est-ce que nous réalisons figurez-vous
correspond à la promesse
que peu de pays le font et parfois les
promesses de mise à disposition sont
importantes mais que derrière le niveau
d'engagement est plus faible et donc si
vous regardez bien les missions de
réassurance aérienne les missions de
planification en état majeur ou les
missions de sécurité en Méditerranée en
Atlantique pour prendre des choses très
concrètes en fait nous sommes souvent
soit meneurs soit jumeaux des Américains
si vous regardez la Méditerranée vous
avez le groupe aéronaval bouche et notre
groupe ironavale très concrets si vous
me permettez juste sur ce point ce que
vous dites est très important parce que
avec un certain nombre de collègues moi
je siège à l'Assemblée parlementaire de
l'OTAN et souvent de la part de certains
alliés et amis on entend des propos qui
doutent un petit peu comme toujours
selon une vieille tradition de
l'engagement de la France au sein de
l'OTAN c'est quand même important de
rappeler que on est là et on respecte
effectivement la totalité des
engagements que nous prenons et ils sont
importants que soit en Roumanie et
Pays-Bas Pologne etc c'est quand même
plus les grandes manœuvres que l'on fait
communément avec ses clés et en fait
c'est clé de repasser par les effets
militaires réels là où trop souvent il
peut y avoir une petite technocratie
hôtelienne qui pourrait nous emmener
uniquement vers la part de financement
commun ou quand est-ce qu'on réalise les
2 % de PIB au bout d'un moment c'est une
alliance militaire donc c'est surtout la
qualité la réalité et la nature même des
missions militaires réelles qui sont
exécutées et là-dessus on a évidemment
rien à reprocher à la contribution
militaire française me semble-t-il
monsieur le Center cerise sur la
comparaison avec les autres les autres
pays et l'Afrique en Afrique on s'était
dit je crois que ça valait le coup de
faire une séance peut-être dédiée parce
que moi je honnête avec vous quand on se
dit que la France perd de l'influence en
Afrique on a un raccourci qui me paraît
bien rapide parce qu'en fait c'est comme
si on parlait de l'Europe c'est un
continent énorme l'Afrique ok c'est
qu'il y a des pays dans lequel il y a
des déprises pour les raisons que vous
connaissez et qui a des pays dans lequel
ça crée une réaffirmation de liens et de
volonté de travail avec la France qui
est énorme donc c'est une réalité donc
en fait d'ailleurs pardon mais nos
partenaires africains quand on dit
l'Afrique ils le prenne plutôt mal ils
nous disent non non nous on est on est
peut-être africains
on est tchadien on est à Djibouti enfin
bref donc je pense que ça vaut le coup
le moment venu peut-être avec Catherine
Colonna parce que l'approche n'est pas
que militaire dans cette commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense de
faire un focus Afrique je vous ai écrit
des récemment sur le sujet je l'annonce
du Sano collègues nous avons un débat
sur le rôle de la France en Afrique au
titre de l'article 50-1 le 6 juin au
soir donc on aura l'occasion d'aborder y
compris la dimension sécurité exactement
moi ce que je vois c'est que les pays
dans lequel nous avons des bases
prépositionnées et un désir de France et
il y a même beaucoup de choses qui nous
sont demandées en plus en matière de
formation notamment sur les nouveaux
métiers spatial renseignements guerre
électronique enfin malheureusement le
combat contre le terrorisme armé devient
aussi plus technologique qui ne l'était
et on voit bien qu'il y a un vrai besoin
de France dans certains pays et
inversement certaines jantes nous ont
évincé dans les raisons pour les raisons
que vous connaissez mais je pense que si
on veut rendre aussi hommage au pays
d'Afrique qui aiment la France et qui
travaillent avec nous je pense qu'il
faut qu'on les globalise plus parce que
quand il nous regarde nous élite
politique parisienne ou française ils se
disent mais pourquoi vous nous mettez
dans le même dans le même sac en
commentaire que je fais mais je crois
qu'il est important pour pour la suite
comparaison internationale bon déjà un
c'est toujours très compliqué de se
comparer puisque vous avez des pays qui
mettent les pensions dans le budget
militaire si quelqu'un des budgets au
sens autant d'ailleurs du terme et là
vous voyez on parle de 413 milliards on
est hors ancien combattants et
hors-pension si vous rajoutez non pas
les anciens combattants mais les
pensions sur les critères autant vous
rajoutez 10 milliards d'euros
typiquement à la fin de la période c'est
pas 69 milliards d'euros au sens de
l'OTAN mais 80 puisque faut rajouter les
pensions
quand vous faites cela
si on se compare avec ce que nous on se
les autres pays je dis annonce parce que
on revient nos affaires de exécution à
l'Europe ou pas en plus les cadres sont
pas toujours les mêmes en matière de
programmation globalement on passera
devant l'Allemagne et devant la
Grande-Bretagne sur la base de ces
critères là mais une fois qu'on a dit ça
comparer des pays qu'on la dissuasion
nucléaire et ceux qui ne l'ont pas
comparer des pays qui ont des outre-mer
et ceux qui n'ont pas comparer des pays
qui ont des armées d'emplois avec des
cultures expéditionnaires avec des
capacités de projection le bout de la
planète avec ceux qui n'en ont pas c'est
toujours très compliqué sans compter le
modèle de réserve etc donc en fait ça on
peut faire cet effort parfois le même
sur le nombre de soldats après tout
c'est aussi un bon autre critère qu'on
pourrait regarder mais très vite en fait
la notion même de souveraineté une
mission n'est pas du tout la même en
tout cas si on se compare avec
l'Allemagne on a la dissuasion nucléaire
dedans on a des territoires d'outre-mer
et puis après il y a un autre critère
qui est plus malheureux c'est le nombre
de tuer de blessés et qui dit aussi
quelque chose de l'exposition de nos
forces armées aux missions les plus
dangereuses ça aussi c'est quelque chose
évidemment qu'il faut qu'il faut
regarder de près
monsieur le sénateur Laurent alors sur
la diffusion nucléaire je connais les
positions évidemment de du Parti
communiste français sur ce sujet comme
je le disais hier au député le coq et
Roussel dans l'hémicycle à l'Assemblée
les positions sont constantes et connues
et avec beaucoup de cohérence de la part
du Parti communiste je partage pas
évidemment cette cette conviction je
considère que la diffusion nucléaire est
utile et comme l'avait dit le général de
Gaulle le désarmement ne peut pas se
regarder de manière unilatérale pour
reciter le général sur les chiffres le
chiffre précis que je peux donner dans
cette commission c'est que l'agrégat
dissuasion correspond à 13% de la de la
copie globale alors comme la copie
globale augmente bah ça veut dire aussi
évidemment qu'ils augmentations à la
matière après sur un certain nombre de
détails
comme le disait très joliment pire
Messmer lorsqu'il était mise des armées
à certains secrets militaires
correspondent certaines discrétions
budgétaires fin de citation
ça c'est
joli parce que ça dit aussi quelque
chose évidemment à nos compétiteurs sur
le segment de la dissuasion donner des
chiffres très précis dit aussi quelque
chose à nos compétiteurs après moi je
peux regarder avec nos équipes pour
essayer quand même dans ce qui est
exploitable publiquement de vous donner
évidemment le maximum d'informations
mais le chiffre de 13% vient en
contradiction avec quelques rumeurs du
moment effectivement comme comme je vous
l'exposé tout à l'heure néanmoins ce que
je pourrais vous développer une fois
prochaine c'est évidemment les efforts
de modernisation de la dissuasion quand
même des choses qui qui sont
complètement explicables soit pour les
vecteurs nouvelle génération de Classe
des sénéle par définition ça correspond
à des efforts importants ça permet aussi
de sanctuariser notre filière propulsion
nucléaire qui nous sera utile évidemment
pour le porte-avion enfin
comme celle du porte-avion est utile
pour le SNA les snele tout se lit on
voit bien que la discrétion acoustique
est un sujet clé donc comment on a une
génération de sous-marins plus discret
et pour le coup ça soutient aussi des
efforts sur le conventionnel un Sénat a
pas besoin d'être aussi discret qu'un
c'est autant de technologie de
savoir-faire français que l'on tire
évidemment vers le haut qui sont
absolument précieux pareil quand on
réfléchit à la succession du Rafale avec
le Scaff quel que soit la forme que
prendra le Scaff il faut évidemment un
avion qui succédera au Rafale et qui
permet évidemment de d'intégrer les
forces ADN stratégiques ça c'est
évidemment aussi un des marqueurs qui
correspond aussi à ce qu'il faut
financer et puis évidemment la
génération de système de domicile dans
la composante aéroportée comme dans la
composante
océanique qui à chaque fois évidemment
correspond à des à des mises à jour je
rappelle qu'un missile océanique c'est
pratiquement une petite fusée Ariane à
certains égards avec tout ce que ça
suggère aussi en matière de technologie
et donc évidemment ce sont des
générations qui avancent de manière
incrémentale sous l'autorité la
direction de l'éducation militaire du
CEA et la Délégation Générale pour
l'armée
monsieur le ministre merci infiniment de
vous avoir de vous être prêté à cette
longue audition qui est quand même été
très dense je pense que le fait d'avoir
répondu après chaque rapport à donner un
peu de dynamique à cette à cette
audition comme vous le l'avez compris
par l'intensité et la précision des
questions notre commission à l'intention
comme c'est la mission constitutionnelle
qui les confiait de faire un travail
approfondi sans concession mais dans un
esprit responsable et constructif et
c'est du reste ce qui prendra la forme
du questionnaire que très rapidement les
rapporteurs vont rédiger à votre
intention auquel nous joindrons les
questions budgétaires de Dominique
delaige de telle sorte de avant dans
débattre définitivement d'avoir une idée
d'une idée précise de ce qui va de ce
que cette loi va
changer un petit peu dans les dans les
orientations de notre défense je retiens
quand même effectivement la dimension
d'adaptabilité qui me semble quand même
importante parce que 2030 c'est loin et
on vu l'état du monde on sait pas très
bien dans quel état et dans quelle
situation nous serons à faire donc il
n'est je rappelle les propos de l'amiral
Vendée qui disaient sur le futur
porte-avion il sera peut-être tout
autant porte drone que pour cet avion
parce que là aussi il faut prendre en
compte les l'évolution des technologies
merci en tous les cas monsieur le
ministre on va poursuivre cet exercice
théorique demain sur Orion pour ceux et
celles qui se joignent cette cette
aventure merci en tous les quatre de la
précision de vos réponses merci à vos
équipes et à bientôt pour une prochaine
audition on aura peut-être plusieurs
mais nous irons jusqu'au bout de ce
magnifique dossier qui doit illustrer la
compétence et le sérieux de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées du Sénat
merci